Hello everybody!
April Fools!
The screen... we're so back!
Hello.
Today I'm a little naked today.
What is this knife I'm holding?
I'm making a salad.
What do you mean?
I'm... I'm... I'm my true form.
Also my brain today.
I just need you guys to know.
Um... I had four hours of sleep.
My brain's a little bit more enhanced than usual.
I might be a little more stupid than usual because like...
I had like three to four hours of sleep today because I was working.
I... I spent my entire night... I went to bed at like 9am today.
And then... yes today.
I went to bed at 9am today.
And then...
yes today.
I went to bed at 9am today.
And then like I woke up at...
What time did I woke up?
12?
At like 12 or 1pm.
So my brain is not okay.
But that's fine!
Today's the best day to not be okay.
It's April Fools!
If I do something fucked up...
I can be like... Ha ha!
April Fools!
That's not me.
That's not my intrusive thoughts thinking.
I'm just joking.
I'm just joking with you guys.
April Fools!
You'll never know what is right or wrong.
So yes, my brain currently...
Might need a little bit more oxygen today.
But I sort of like fucked up with that.
So...
Right now I'm actually on a stream of consciousness.
Where I'm not even thinking about what I'm saying.
And... Oh god this is not a good idea.
This is not...
Usually I have...
I know it's really fucking wild.
But usually I would have this little filter on.
Like a little... you know...
Don't be a brand risk filter.
You know?
Like...
You're... You're a...
You're an internet personality now Doki.
Don't say anything that you will regret.
But today...
Today is a little risky.
When there's not enough oxygen going to my brain.
It is...
It is a little risky right now.
For me to stream because...
I don't think I did not have a lot of sleep.
So we'll see how this goes.
We're gonna see how this goes.
But it's okay.
It's okay.
What are you gonna do?
Cancel a tomato?
I'm a fucking fruit.
You can't do that to me.
Anyway, yes.
Happy April Fool's everybody.
I hope you guys...
I hope...
I hope you guys enjoyed...
Welcoming back our intro.
It was...
It's finally here!
I know like April F...
I could have just played the intro for an hour straight.
But I sort of actually really wanted to play the murder of Sonic the Hedgehog.
And...
It's been like a game that I wanted to play since last year.
So like...
I was like...
You know what?
I was so...
I was so sad.
I was actually waiting to like...
You know...
Cause like...
Japan is really, really good with like April Fools.
And...
Um...
So I was like...
Oh wait...
Cause like they released...
Cause you know...
Japan really goes like all out when it comes to like April Fool pranks for some reason.
I don't know why.
But like...
It's always Japan that does like...
Like...
Pull all stops and does like a hundred percent on April Fools jokes.
You know?
Like people in America...
They don't try as hard as Japan.
Like...
Like Japan will make like actual like...
I was so scared.
Killala finally announced like a new season.
But I couldn't even tell if it was real.
I was like...
Please don't be April Fools.
Please don't be a sick April Fools joke.
Because they've done this before.
They will release like fully animated trailers.
And just be like...
Kihi April Fools.
I swear.
They've done it.
They did it for Panty and Stalk...
I remember they did it for Panty and Stalking before they actually announced like...
They did that before for Panty and Stalking.
And it hurt.
It actually hurt so much.
So I couldn't tell.
I couldn't tell.
So like...
Anyway...
Um...
Before I posted my schedule...
I was actually waiting to see if like Japan was gonna do this.
Like if they were gonna release anything similar to the murder of Sonic the Hedgehog.
So I can be like...
So I could...
I could be like...
Okay I could get in on this.
The FOMO.
Flavor of the month.
I could get in on the April Fools.
If they release another game.
On April Fools.
But they didn't.
They didn't release anything new.
I was so sad.
I was like...
Oh my god.
No April Fools flavor of the month?
What is this?
How would we stream or survive without our regularly released content?
Oh my god.
We need new content.
But it's okay.
It's okay.
I haven't played the murder of Sonic the Hedgehog.
So it's almost new for all of us.
It's almost new.
I'm so sad.
I love Sonic the Hedgehog.
The real April Fools.
No fucking free games to play on April Fools.
How is this possible?
So yes.
Anyway, Meddy thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I had a ratatouille flashback moment with the intro.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Don't worry guys.
In two hours.
I think I scheduled it for two hours.
The full intro will be uploaded as a video.
Oh my god, Sonic!
The game was actually developed by the social team.
Oh my god!
America!
Fuck yeah!
Oh my god!
If I can get fact checked by anybody, I'm happy it was Sonic the Hedgehog.
Sonic the Hedgehog!
Where is my sequel?
What happened?
The Sega of America!
I'm happy that... you know what?
I'm not upset that I got actuallyed.
Because I got... who else?
Alright, who else could have got actuallyed by the official team?
The official Sonic the Hedgehog though.
Come on!
I wear that pride.
I wear that with honor.
I don't worry.
What happened?
Sonic!
Did you guys peaked?
You guys fell off!
No!
Oh my god.
Anyway, I'm super... I'm super duper excited to...
Finally play... I have like no...
I have like no actual knowledge of whatever this game is.
The only thing I know about this game is that I saw a screenshot of Sonic doing the Yamcha pose.
So that is like literally my only point of knowledge for this game.
Okay, and then I looked at the... Also, by the way, how's the sound by the way?
Um...
Is the... Is the... Is the sound okay?
That's actually crazy though.
Oh my god, Sonic.
I can't believe the official Sonic team is here.
Watching a tomato play this game.
A year late by the way.
Okay, so like I know it's not just a visual novel.
Because, um...
I was looking... Okay, let's see if my sound guy is awake.
Uh...
Alright, they're not in my chat.
So I assume they're not awake.
Oh, wait.
They are!
They are in my chat!
Okay, I know that there's more to this.
Because I looked at assist mode.
And why the fuck is there invisibility?
And, uh...
Invincibility?
And then remove pitfalls.
I was like, oh, this is not a regular...
This is not a regular visual novel.
I was just like, this is...
What do you mean?
Pitfalls?
What does this mean?
This is not a regular...
There's a journalist mode.
Why is there a journalist mode in my visual novel?
Anyway...
Um...
Yes, don't mind the knife.
I'm just making my salad.
So, um...
If anybody like...
If anybody gets stabbed...
It wasn't my fault.
They walked into it, okay?
Okay, I'm just saying...
If I start walking around...
Extending my arm out...
Holding a knife...
And like...
I just walk forward...
Is it really my fault if somebody else walks into my knife?
Is it really my fault?
I would say that like...
It would be an act...
It was like their fault for being stupid enough to walk into my knife.
Okay, guys?
Like, how is that my fault?
Like, they could just...
You know, they could just like...
Walk the other way.
Like, oh my god, just turn around.
Hahaha...
What is that red stain?
It's just tomato sauce.
You know?
I was just making a salad.
Alright.
Anyway.
Let's...
Let's fucking play the murder of Sonic the Hedgehog.
Phew.
Made it on the train 15 minutes ahead of schedule.
So far, so good for my first day on the job.
Oh, I totally forgot my name tag.
Uh...
It isn't ready yet.
I should make...
Wait, is that me?
Is that my Sonic OC?
I'll just...
I'll just sign my name here.
Oh my god!
Hahaha!
He's red too!
Just like me!
How did they know?
I can't believe it!
That's my official Sonic OC, guys.
Um...
Okay.
Doki...
FPS...
VTuber...
TTV...
Oh, wait.
Uh...
Okay.
Doki...
Tomato...
FPS...
VTuber...
Okay, there.
There we go.
That feels better.
Alright.
C.I.
Thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you, thank you!
Doki, I passed my PhD today.
Let's go!
Real 90 Roblox!
Thank you for confirming.
Thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you, thank you!
Doki Mado?
Oh my god, you're right.
I need people to know I'm a VTuber.
I need, like, Doki Mado FPS VTube.
There we go.
I need people to know I'm a VTuber.
Alright.
Doki Mado FPS VTube.
Did I spell that right?
Yeah!
Yes.
Oh my god, that's me!
Hope passengers can read my scribble.
I can't believe it.
I'm an official Sonic OC.
Dining car.
Uh oh.
Am I nervous?
Is this first day on the job jitters?
Working the train's dining car can be so...
See?
This is why I have a knife!
I'm a chef!
Come on, Doki Mado FPS VTube.
Shake it off!
Slap.
Doki Mado FPS VTube.
Okay, maybe it was a bad idea to have an incredibly long name.
Did I, uh, just see you hitting yourself?
Mr. Conductor, sir.
How are you doing this morning?
Ho ho ho.
Quite alright, my dear.
I'm doing myself, though feeling a little bit bittersweet.
Is that because you're...
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Guys!
Guys, I need a promotion.
Okay.
I have a family to feed.
The family is me.
Oh, trying to butter me up on the very first day, are we?
Alas, today is my last day as the Conductor.
I'm retiring after 32 wonderful years.
Time for me and the Mirage Express to say goodbye to one another.
Oh, congratulations on retirement, sir!
Thank you.
My wife is...
Oh, he has a...
No, it's okay.
I can be the...
The trading side.
Very excited about it.
She's already got our plane tickets to Spagonia Unlocked.
Oh, Locked.
Our shower's been on the fritz, so I'm excited to use the hotels.
Ha ha!
I can see why his wife's excited.
Enough of my quibbles.
Today is your first day working the dining car.
Here's the menu for today.
Menu added to your inventory.
Oh, I got the menu.
I can open up the inventory at any time to see what's on that menu.
It features Chili Dog Instant Ramen.
And Chicken Cordon Bleu.
I like how Instant Ramen is in there.
It looks so fancy!
Imagine eating like, Instant Ramen at such a fancy VIP.
There's a fucking chandelier!
How is there like, a chandelier in this fucking...
Like, in this train?
I don't know.
I feel like having a chandelier on a moving train seems incredibly fucking dangerous.
Um...
Why do you look so nervous?
All we have on the train is a microwave.
Ha ha ha ha!
Though...
I'm sure a little quiz is in order.
A quiz?
Which of these do we serve in the dining car?
Oh.
Chicken...
Oh, I read!
I can...
Guys, for April Fools, the biggest joke right now is that I can read.
Ding ding ding!
Ding!
Glad you can read the menu okay.
Bwahaha!
A little about the vessel.
This is a state of the art, high speed, smart train.
With all the latest gadgets.
The train can really handle anything you throw at it.
But yet we serve Instant Ramen?
We've had a lot of adventures together.
Me and this train.
It's not easy to leave.
After 32 years?
I don't blame it for being wistful.
This train is exclusively used for events.
It's not a passenger train.
All the budget went to the fucking chandelier.
Imagine eating Instant Ramen with champagne and chandeliers.
Ha ha ha ha!
I remember that from the interview.
What's the event today?
A murder mystery party.
Wait, you mean Sonic isn't actually dead?
I got click baited.
Sonic Team!
Ha ha ha ha!
I can't believe he's not actually dead!
What's the point?
What?
Nothing better than some throws to end my tenure as conducted.
Guests will be funneled here to the dining car as a home base, so to speak.
I'll be with you to gather tickets.
But after that, you'll be on your own.
So I'll need you to do everything in your power to make sure our paying guests are well taken care of.
Understood?
I can't afford to lose my job.
This is all I have left.
You sure can't.
The severance pay is lousy.
Ha ha ha!
Doors to the Mirage Express are opening.
All aboard!
I can't believe Sonic is actually still alive.
I know!
What the fuck was the point?
Ha ha ha ha!
Why did I bring a knife for?
That's so messed up.
Oh.
Amy!
Wow!
Oh, sorry, wait.
This train is incredible!
What fascinating tech!
I forgot what Vector sounds like.
He's a gator.
You're right, Dez.
I could get used to staying on a train like this.
What do you expect?
You know, I always go all out for my birthday parties.
Oh shit.
Ha ha ha ha!
Wait.
Um.
Ha ha ha ha!
Guys, I could never do, like, Rouge Justice.
This train is as elegant as you are, Amy.
I can't promise I won't take anything, though.
Ha ha ha ha!
Oh, wait.
I'm sorry.
Oh, fuck.
I'm like, really?
Fuck, there's so many voices.
Guys, I can't keep up to date with a lot of...
Today I'm a little stupid, so I can't keep up to date with all these voices.
Um.
Whoa!
Calm down there, Rouge.
Did I not just catch you stealing from the train station gif shop?
Howdy!
Ha ha ha ha!
That was my best country accent!
It was a pen, knucklehead.
Who's gonna miss me?
A teeny, tiny pen.
Oh, I love the directing.
What cast of characters am I stuck with?
Get a hold of yourself, Dokimedo FPSVTube.
You're sweating through your uniform.
Oh shit.
Oh my god!
It's the star!
It's him!
Sonic, are you still here?
That's you!
Oh my god!
That's him!
Okay, the main character!
Wait, let me get into the mindset.
Chilly dogs, chilly dogs.
Chilly dogs, chilly dogs!
Hey pal!
Can I get one of those chilly dogs?
They're both the same answer.
What a lovely day to be alive and...
and not dead.
This is an illusion of choice.
It's literally the same answer.
Okay, radio friend.
Well, aren't you friendly?
Why can't I be normal for one second?
Sonic, wait until I announce everyone's rules to get food.
Sorry about that, birthday girl.
I'll be coming around to collect everyone's tic...
I almost said TikToks.
I'll be coming...
Oh my god, what's wrong with me?
I'll be coming around to collect everyone's tickets.
Please have them out and ready.
You'll join me, Dokimedo FPSVTube, won't you?
Just click on whoever you'd like to talk with and we'll collect their tickets.
Okay, got it.
Alright.
Who are you?
You never introduced yourself.
Oh my god!
This is... this is my actual Sonic OC.
Here.
Thank you.
Everything is in order.
He seems concerned about something.
You know what I wish?
What would be the best gift in the whole wide world?
If they like, re-released the Shadow game where he holds a gun.
I feel like...
Please...
I don't understand!
Why we don't have...
We have so many remakes.
But not the one where we save the president.
The most important...
We make the most...
The most important game of all.
I wanna fucking be Shadow the Hedgehog and shoot somebody.
Like, I don't understand.
I don't understand why we can't have that.
Why we don't have that.
Is there anything we can help you with?
Hmm...
Do you sell gift bags here?
Um...
No.
Sadly.
But I have a plastic grocery bag in the back I could get for you.
Hmm...
That stare...
Oh, so cold.
Doki made a FPS VTube.
You're shivering.
Do you need me to fetch your jacket?
Oh my gosh, what will your wife think?
Oh, no.
No, I'm good.
He's so cool.
He's so fucking cool.
Okay.
Howdy.
Can I please get your ticket?
I think that's a ticket.
But I really don't want to argue with this guy.
Everything looks good.
Thank you.
Seems the conductor doesn't want to argue either.
Hmm...
Can I get your ticket, young'un?
Right here, sir.
Thank you.
May I offer you any of the snacks we have on board?
No, thank you.
When I travel, I always pack my own Sparkle Gelatin.
It's a sparkly jelly that can melt any jaded heart.
No way I brought my own Sparkle Gelatin with me too.
It's my first day.
And I was a little nervous.
Oh, my God.
We're going to be best friends, Tails.
Honestly, always be like really good friends with like the smart kid.
Because like they'll always have your...
Because like the reason why is that what if they become a millionaire?
It's like you'll become the millionaire and then you'll always get like very expensive gifts later on.
Also, they're good friends too, by the way.
It's not always about...
Bye.
It's not always about the money, you know.
It's not always about the money.
They'll be really good friends.
But also the bonus.
The bonus is that they'll be like, hey, you want that iPhone?
Don't worry, man.
I just got my allowance.
Let me get that for you.
Don't be nervous.
You're doing great so far.
We're Sparkle Gelatin buddies.
Bye.
Unless they become a doctor.
Then they don't make any money.
Alright,
let's see.
We'll talk to Sonic last.
A princess such as myself must always be punctual.
Princess?
Did she just say princess?
I actually don't know the lore with her.
I think like... I think her and the chameleon... I don't really know much lore about them.
But I think they're like more like the comics, right?
Like...
Um...
Aren't they like... Aren't they like...
More so like...
Like Sonic comic characters?
Because I don't know much about Blaze or...
Or...
The Iguana Kid.
Or Gator.
It don't mean I'm asking.
Are you visiting from somewhere?
A separate dimension actually.
A separate what?
Just here for Amy's birthday.
Then I'll hop back to my own dimension.
They're not comic characters.
Wait, which... Which game are they from?
I quite prefer the birthday cake from this world more than on my own.
I'm exci... I meant I'm a bit excited.
Ho ho ho!
You don't say.
Well, I hope you enjoy your stay princess.
Many games.
I like how the Sonic 06 and the Sonic Rush people are fighting each other right now.
And I'm just like who's she?
Should I bow?
Do I bow before the princess?
What are you doing?
Please.
Get up.
Why can I not win with this group?
Alright, let's see.
Who's he?
She?
He?
Could we please see your ticket?
Of course.
Excellent.
Thank you.
And I hope you enjoy your stay with us.
Absolutely.
I appreciate it.
There's a calmness about...
Oh, he was super calm.
Sorry, I was...
I have no idea who this person is.
I just knew he was a chameleon.
There's a calmness about him.
Something about his presence puts me at ease.
Do you consider me calming?
He's looking right at me.
I study ninjutsu.
I believe one can communicate through the subconscious.
Fucking nerd.
Wow, ninjutsu?
That sounds like a lot of difficult training.
Can you cling on to walls?
Cling on to walls?
What kind of question is that?
We...
I must certainly can.
The conductor looks a bit too smug at that answer.
Who else are you missing?
Oh no, Gator.
Hello, my friend.
Can I get your ticket?
Yeah, of course.
As a gentleman of upsetting morals, I love to show you my...
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Maybe not.
Maybe put that down.
Don't need to show me your ticket, man.
Farewell.
Get out.
Don't you worry.
We'll take a look around for you and see if it turns up.
That would be amazing.
Thanks a million.
Seems as though we should keep our eyes peeled for his ticket.
Get out.
Paying customers only.
Can I please get the birthday girl's ticket?
Why certainly.
Oh shit.
I don't know what he said.
Well, the birthday discount certainly helped.
It must not have been important.
Who doesn't love a good bargain?
And a murder mystery train?
Just sounds so exciting.
It's right out of my alley.
Who doesn't love a good thrill?
You see, I'm a girl who loves a good truth.
I'm a girl who loves a good truth.
I'm a girl who loves a good crime.
Oh no.
She's one of those people.
Maybe I should leave her to have fun.
Before we move along for you...
Before we move along for you, miss.
Oh, have fun!
Thank you!
Where do I use this?
That unlocks any door on the train.
Happy birthday!
The birthday girl gets the birthday key.
It's practically traditional.
Wait, the birthday girl gets to cheat?
That's not fair!
Why the fuck does she get to play on journalist mode?
And I actually have to try.
Very useful.
Well used this wisely.
Thank you!
Alright.
Fuck.
Okay, rouge.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Well, hello, YouTube.
Sorry.
What can I do for you?
Good morning, ma'am.
Can we get your ticket?
My, my.
How forward.
Let me fetch it for you.
Wait, is it like in her...
Where did she... Where did she get it?
Come back if you need anything.
Anything else?
You hear?
Wow, she's so polite.
Very easy to talk to as well.
Ma'am, I saw you sneak that $20 bill out of my pocket.
Wait, what?
He has a wife!
And a...
And he already has a side...
He already has a train wife too.
And he already has a train wife too.
Gonna have to kindly ask for that back.
Oh, this was yours?
Must have slipped out.
Here you go.
I may not actually be the best at judging characters.
Alright, Sonic's the last...
ticket, please.
Oh wait, sorry, that's conductor.
I thought that was...
Thank you kindly.
Happy that someone as renowned as yourself aboard.
Huh?
Don't worry about it.
I just like helping.
When Eggman took over, I truly feared the worst.
But my kids swore you would swoop in eventually.
And you did!
I can't offer much other than my sincere gratitude.
Don't sweat a thing.
I'm glad you and your family are safe.
Wait a minute.
Is he...
Is he Sonic the Hedgehog?
Okay, to be fair, how many other blue hedgehogs out there?
How the fuck did I not know this was Sonic?
If I didn't know it was Sonic, I should have known by Amy Tale's shadow.
And now I'm like, whoa, there's Amy Tale.
I wonder who this blue hedgehog is.
Oh my god!
I can't believe that's Sonic the Hedgehog!
I promise you an excellent stay on our train.
How many blue hedgehogs are fucking in this world anyway?
Sonic, have fun now.
Yes!
Have fun!
Have fun now!
Will do!
Thanks!
Oh wait, there's one more.
That's not a character.
Mmm, yum.
Ha ha!
Mmm, yummy!
Don't mind if I do.
Dokimedo FPS VTube.
Those are for our guests, you know.
Train, be sure Dokimedo FPS VTube only gets one of those if they ask.
Hmm.
Okay.
You're like what about like, there's...
There's metal Sonic.
Yes!
He's made of metal!
Like, he's fucking metal!
The Sonic's not made of metal!
The arms just kinda not?
Actually, uh, Train.
The conductor wants me to have the whole plate.
Hmm.
Ha ha ha!
Good try, young boss.
What about my OC?
Jeremiah the blue hedgehog who looks just like Sonic.
Did I talk to everybody?
Oh wait, what's this?
What's sticking out the napkin holder?
Oh, it's the Gator's ticket!
Say, wasn't someone looking for that ticket earlier?
Let's be sure to return this to its rightful owner.
Alright, let's make sure no one uses their ticket as a napkin.
Alright, hello!
I found your ticket.
Yeah, we might just have what you need.
Donky Medoh FPS VTube, why don't you show our friend here what we picked up?
Look, I found a menu.
Oh, I'm starved!
I'll take one of each!
On second thought, maybe I'll wait a bit.
Donky Medoh FPS VTube, I was referring to the other thing we picked up.
Oh, right, sorry!
Oh no, maybe they're hungry!
If they want to order food, they'll have to pay for it and then we get more money, right?
Can I?
Oh, it's the same thing.
Okay.
I was gonna say, would he call me stupid if I do it again?
Ah!
Here it is!
That's my ticket!
Thanks so much to you both!
Was really worried you'd kick me out and I missed the murder mystery!
Oh, oh!
Old Donky Medoh FPS VTube!
Here we'll have their hands full kicking you out!
You're right!
I wouldn't leave without a fight!
Ha ha ha ha!
Whoa!
Wait, who made me both microwave expert and security guard?
Wait, am I the only staff here?
Other than the train?
Where are the other people?
Wait a minute.
Where are the other Sonic OCs?
You're both all right in my book!
Thanks again for the assist!
This is like the most unrealistic thing.
There only being one self-insert Sonic OC.
Of course!
Just let us know if you need anything else!
Okay everyone!
Time for me to read out everyone's rules for the murder mystery!
And that's my cue to leave!
I must prepare the driver's compartment for departure!
Ah, the conductor's car.
You remember our promise, yeah?
You'll do everything in your power to make sure our guests have a safe and enjoyable time on the Mirage Express!
Absolutely!
You can count on me!
The one person, you know, in charge!
On the first day!
For a celebrity!
And train?
Assist Dokimedo FPS VTube if they need any help, won't you?
This is my self-insert Sonic OC fanfiction.
That's all I need to hear.
You have my trust.
Nothing more heartwarming than a conductor and his train.
Just me and my train wife.
Excellent!
I'll be off.
I must take my leave, everyone.
Please, have a phenomenal time!
And don't worry about mucking up the place's otter.
This train is state of the art and our systems were dealing with all of that.
For everything else, please talk to Dokimedo FPS VTube here if you need anything else.
Sounds good!
Absolutely!
Okay, wait, they sound the same now.
Oh no.
I made Tails and Sonic sound the same and I didn't realize.
Because I can only do three voices.
Okay.
Absolutely!
Will do!
Okay, bye now!
I like that guy!
Thank you all for following the outfit guide.
I sent you.
You all look...
Oh yeah, by the way, do you guys know like Mirage from Apex voices Sonic the Hedgehog?
I sent you.
You all look amazing!
I trust you all read your lore cards as well?
Lore cards?
That must be the details of their motivations.
I suppose it makes sense.
Lore cards aren't read out loud otherwise people will know the murderer's intentions.
Yeah!
You guys didn't know that?
It's the same voice actor.
Now, on to the nitty gritty for the murder mystery game.
One of you will be murdered and the rest are suspects.
Man, I wonder who's going to be murdered in the murder of Sonic the Hedgehog.
Everyone has assigned roles for characters they will be playing.
Participation is required.
For it is my birthday!
Of course!
Birthday girl makes the rules!
Sonic, you are a ship captain and you'll be stationed in the conductor car.
Naturally, that's where the captain would go.
Tails, you are the detective.
You'll be here in the dining car.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
You'll be here in the dining car, too.
I'll wait for you.
I'm sorry.
You'll be here in the dining car.
Exactly.
I'll wait for you.
Your birthday in the lived room.
I'm sure you're ready.
What?
It's a train!
No wonder he's... Okay, now I understand why he's a cowboy.
Sounds fun.
Wait, why the fuck is the butcher in the library?
Wouldn't the butcher be in the dining car?
This doesn't make sense, Amy.
You already fucked it up.
Like, all the other ones fit!
Why the fuck is the butcher in the library?
Oh my god.
I'm cooking.
This is my self-insert fanfiction.
Very educated butcher.
Both found in the library.
Hear that, Espio?
We get to hang out together!
And do what?
Yeah, what are we going to do?
Reeeeeeeend?
Maybe we can make a tower of books or something.
Yeah, books.
Shadow is the locksmith hanging out in the looom.
And last but not least, me!
I'm the locksmith!
The Dreadless Reporter!
I'll be moseying around with everyone!
Did you get all that?
Yeah, a tower made of... books.
Did it have the April Fools?
Oh my god, actual dreadless mode!
Oh my god, she's actually...
oh my god!
She's actually a Dreadless!
Don't worry, I'll do your...
Don't worry, I'll do your decimal.
Will she re...
No, okay, I don't want her to repeat that.
I was listening!
Hope that's okay.
Stop!
More than alright!
You can help ensure everyone's following their rules!
Ugh, that reminds me!
Oh shit, thank god I have a map.
I have a map for each of you!
Everyone's station is marked on the map as well.
How convenient!
Map added to my inventory.
Oh thank god, it won't get lost.
Okay guys, I don't need you guys to help me remember.
I have a map.
The rules of the game are as follows.
There is a murder amongst you all.
The murder can kill a single participant, however they choose.
But you must physically be present with the victim for it to count.
Everyone else must collect evidence throughout the train and use it to integrate.
Interrogate fellow passengers to figure out who's done it.
The murder will lie to get out of being accused.
So inspect everything you can.
Find clues.
And interrogate.
Oh my god, it's like Phoenix Wright in Among Us.
I'll set a timer for you.
One hour.
So everyone can mingle and the murder can do their thing.
Is everyone ready?
Yeah!
Let's play!
Sounds like everyone's excited!
Yeah!
Stop, stop.
Everyone at your stations!
Alright.
Let's find some clues.
Can someone die yet?
Ah, this is so exciting!
A mystery is unfolding right under our very noses!
How thrilling!
I know, it's kinda scary!
Oh man, I'm...
Oh man, I'm nervous too!
Shouldn't you two be out here mingling with everyone?
Yeah, detective, do your fucking job!
Who hired this kid to be a detective?
He's a child!
Well, actually, the detective and the journalist can't be the murderer.
Wait, why can't they?
They can fucking kill if they want to.
Like, I think killing as a detective is like the perfect alibi.
They can't arrest me if I'm the law.
So we're stuck here for an hour before going out and scoping the place.
This way, there's always a neutral party.
Makes sense to me.
Seems as though Amy's more excited about deciphering the mystery anyway.
What do you think everyone's doing?
I don't know, murder?
Except for the people in the library, they're doing something else.
Oh, probably inspecting their stations and talking amongst one another.
Everyone has a role to play.
So they must be exploring their characters.
Do you know what their character motivations are, Amy?
No, the lore cards are confidential.
No one knows but the person who received them.
Wait, but who made the lore cards?
I thought you made it, Amy.
Didn't you distribute them?
Oh, what's this?
Wait, I thought we're not supposed to know your lore tales.
Oh my god, minus one RP.
My backstory is that I was best friends with a flickie that decided to join the evil Dr. Eggman.
Kickstarting my desire for justice in the world.
My lore is that I'm a nosy person turned a journalist.
She's so happy about that.
Not gonna lie, that kinda sounds fun.
I wish I wasn't stuck on microwave duty.
Huh?
The train started moving!
It's so fast!
Grab onto something!
What is going on?
Wait, a train isn't supposed to move?
It's a fucking train.
I'm slipping!
Hold on!
I can't!
What would be a shame if that chandelier fell?
AHHHHHHHHH!
Plus one RP for me.
I'm so immersed.
Guys, am I immersing you?
Nooooo!
Oh shit, don't worry.
Insurance covers all of this.
Wait, you're...
Wait, what?
This isn't a dining car!
Who moved this here?
It's like...
Oh my god!
It's just like...
It's as if I'm on the train right now!
You're both awake!
Yeah!
It seems the train has slowed down considerably.
Wow, how exhilarating!
I know!
The production on this train is outstanding!
It's definitely more intense than I expected.
I got a concussion!
I'm so tired!
I got a concussion and then we all got knocked out!
And now I have a concussion and we're here now!
So immersive!
It seems we've been knocked into the dining car's closet.
This train can't reach such incredible speeds!
We're getting our money's worth with this experience!
That's for sure!
Is this actually intended?
This is my first day, so...
I'm not really sure.
I don't recall them warning me about this in the interview.
You know I'm getting paid minimum wage for this too.
That's the worst part.
We should go check on the others!
Doki Mato FPSV Tube!
Could you get the door?
Of course!
Getting the door.
Hmm.
Seems the- Oh shit, really?
I wonder by what?
It seems the door is blocked!
I'm not sure.
I don't think it's budging.
Oh shit!
What the fuck could be blocking the door?
It can't be this fucking bookcase in front of me!
No...
Idiot!
Wait, am I actually- Oh my god!
I'm so fucking dumb!
Bro!
My Sonic OC is actually so stupid!
I'm- It was actually the fucking shelf!
That's blocking the door that's in front of me!
Okay.
Alright.
The Sonic OC reflects the streamer.
Um...
Idiot!
Give that falling shelf a whack!
With your pico pico hammer!
Hmm.
Huh?
Let's find another way out.
I'll uh...
Start looking for clues!
I'll start looking for clues!
I'll search over here!
She did it!
She's not the red heron!
You thought she was a- You thought she can't be the murderer!
But she did it!
Sus!
It's always the first person!
I know Amy.
She's hiding something.
Huh?
I suppose she did wake up before us.
Something could have happened.
Listen.
I know I'm the detective here.
But...
All the best detectives have sidekicks.
And I'm gonna need your help.
I'm gonna be Watson!
Let's gather clues on why Amy's acting this way.
And interrogate her about it.
Check out everything you can around the world.
And then we'll show it to Amy.
To uncover the full situation.
Gather evidence and interrogate.
Got it.
We're gonna pull a phoenix right on her.
What's this?
I'll need you to do everything in your power.
To make sure our paying guests are well taken care of.
Understood?
Understood!
Alright.
I guess I gotta act.
I'm gonna go to the bathroom.
You can count on me, Tez.
Don't worry.
I'll make sure you'll have a great murder mystery party.
While I get paid minimum wage.
On my first day.
I won't turn evil like your ex-flicky companion did.
Happa to hear it!
Now let's get searching!
Awfully sweaty over there.
Pretty suspicious.
Something is always hidden in the trash.
Let's check there.
Sadly it's empty.
But on the bright side.
This is a very clean trash bin.
How did I become as optimistic as a kid?
Because he's a child.
They haven't realized how fucked up the real world is.
Oh to be a child again.
What do you think Tez?
Want me to cook any of this for you?
When we get out of here?
Sure!
I normally never make microwave meals.
I prefer to cook.
My cast iron...
Oh my god.
Who let this child cook?
My cast iron skillet has gotten a lot of use lately.
I can cook a mean cast iron pizza.
I've only had mic...
Oh...
I'm so poor.
I haven't had microwave lunches this week.
Alright, let's see.
Ah!
The wet floor sign!
Keeping people alert and safe.
I'm on the college diet right now.
Once I slipped on some spilled juice at the grocery store.
No wet floor sign at all!
Luckily, Sonic was there to catch me.
My hero!
Wow.
Sonic really is as fast as they say.
But he was going so fast.
He also slipped on the juice.
We slid into an older gentleman's shopping cart.
Shredding me.
Well...
It's the thought that counts, I suppose.
Super Persona!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yo, I didn't know you liked Dangan...
I actually love Danganronpa!
I fucking love Danganronpa, man!
I have so many actual like...
Danganronpa... sorry.
Not immersing anyone in it.
Sorry, we're gonna be out of immersive mood right now.
But like, I actually fucking love that show.
And I love the game as well.
And I have like so many Monokuma merch and stuff.
Because I love Monokuma.
Because the original voice actor for Monokuma was Doraemon.
And I fucking love her work.
But yeah, sorry.
Back to immersion!
The shelf blocking our exit is currently not possible.
So we're not budging.
Hey!
Doki made a FPS VTube!
Look closely at this.
Wait...
Is that from the...
Wait, that could be the hammer!
From the something something hammer!
The Piku Piku hammer?
I wonder how this side of the shelf got smashed.
There's nothing this shelf could have fallen into.
I'm not sure this damage wasn't here before.
The chain has too much upkeep.
I feel like this is important.
We should log it.
Check on the... crack on the shelf is added to the...
inventory.
I'm pretty sure like Amy like fucking whacked this shelf.
To lock us in or something.
What?
What's this?
A rod?
Wait, is this...
Wait, that's the hammer!
It broke!
The tip is broken.
It looks like...
It's originally been attached to something.
I'm not sure if it's related to our mystery.
But I like spinning it around.
So we'll keep it.
The stick is added to your inventory.
Yeah, this is the hammer!
It's Amy's hammer!
I think we found enough clues.
Let's go interrogate Amy.
And find what really happened.
Alright Amy, I got you!
What's the latest?
Oh my god, I never even talked to her before.
The game is up.
I'm on my foot now Amy!
Find any clues yet?
I found a spoon!
If we find two more, we can dig ourselves out!
Dig ourselves out?
On a train?
Amy, you stupid bitch.
Okay, that went like Newgrounds real quick.
Uh...
I'll keep looking.
Alright, start... wait.
What do I want to talk to?
Find any clues?
Yeah, that's me calling her stupid.
Uh... start interrogation.
Amy!
We believe you're hiding something from us!
What?
You accuse me?
On my own birthday?
How dare you!
This isn't going to be easy, is it?
It's my birthday!
I've been stuck in here just like the two of you!
What in the world do you think I'm hiding?
Amy was awake before Tails and I were...
What could she have done in that time?
Oh no, what could she have done in that time?
Okay.
Microwave...
Microwave the chili dog.
I told you!
I'm not eating until it's birthday cake time!
Let me think through this again.
Amy was awake before...
Wait, I can just say all the wrong answers.
Like...
There's no stakes involved!
Okay, attempted to...
Okay.
Attempted to escape?
Why would she break the fucking...
The bookshelves?
I don't think you're stealing Ali while Dokimedo, FPSVTube, and I were knocked out.
You attempted to escape the closet.
Prove it!
Huh?
Show more evidence that I attempted to escape or help me search for a way out.
Do we have evidence to prove that?
Dokimedo, FPSVTube.
Let me step you through this.
First, find the correct piece of evidence from your inventory.
You mean the only two evidence that I have?
Once that has been deduced, we must form our arguments to fight back.
Alright, let's do it.
What proves Amy attempted to escape the dining car closet?
Okay, there's this.
The stick.
Which is her hammer.
Hmm...
Let's get... wait, what?
I mean, you need the stick to hit the shelf!
Oh, I guess like the order goes with shelf first and then...
And then like, she'll be like, but what did I use to escape?
And then I'll be like, the hammer!
What?
Sorry!
Some damage on the shelf is supposed to prove something.
It fell over.
Damage makes sense.
Hmm...
You don't have no argument there.
You're just grasping.
Oh, okay Tails, what now?
Well, now we need to follow this train of thought.
How does the crack on the shelf relate to Amy?
I don't know.
What other possible evidence do I have?
Oh, wait.
I had two.
So now I have to explain myself.
See, uh, well, uh, when I get stumped, I like to think.
What would...
Okay, Sonic would not be thinking.
What would Sonic do?
Sonic's a force to be reckoned with.
He's always running for it.
Collecting rings.
Crushing bad.
He never loses.
Like an endless runner game.
I play a lot of this on my phone.
Oh my God.
He's a TikTok kid.
He's an iPad kid.
Sure.
Whatever works.
Just close your eyes and think.
What would Sonic do?
And find your argument.
Well, Sonic could just like, I don't know, run through the door.
Like, couldn't Sonic just break through the door with a sheer speed force?
All right.
Let's prove we're not grasping.
Let's follow the train of thought and fire a comeback like Sonic would do.
Think.
Oh my God.
Oh, wait.
What the fuck?
Wait.
Okay.
All right.
What would Sonic do?
Yes, I'm ready.
What do you mean?
What else do I need to press?
Yes.
Okay.
All right.
Here we go.
Time to collect those rings.
Oh my God.
I zoomed in out of accident.
I'm sorry.
I zoomed that out.
Oh my God.
I got so embarrassed.
It's because it was me.
It's because I'm playing the video game.
They gave me a video game so I zoomed in.
Give me a sec.
I'm locked in.
I'm locked in give me a sec.
Okay, all right here we go.
All right, I'm back.
I'm back now.
I'm a little bit bigger though.
Wait.
Yeah, I'm really... whoa.
Whoa.
Guys keep being... pretend it's all immersion.
Don't get immersed guys.
Don't get immersed.
Okay, we're back.
We're back.
Share the cell phone.
You're telling me on a train this well kept...
That the damage was here before.
Before we arrived?
Well, I...
I believe someone is responsible for hitting that shelf.
You said nothing was around for the shelf to fall onto.
What was the shell hit with then?
All right, your fucking hammer.
The stick.
What is that?
A stick?
You truly believe a stick could do this kind of thing?
Damage.
Think.
Oh no, come on.
Okay.
Hey.
No one now, I know what invincible...
Why the fuck would you need invincibility mode on this?
Like... Oh my god what...
Okay, now I know.
Guys I now know why we need invincibility mode.
You're right.
A stick can do this kind... can do this kind of job.
Sorry!
Oh, the way, but you failed.
The handle to your hammer snapped right off.
It's as we both said.
I tried to get us out all out with my hammer, but I failed.
I gave the shelf one big whack and I figured it was no big deal.
And I tried to hide it, but I suppose my embarrassment got the better of me.
She does look genuinely sorry about the situation.
I never expected your hammer to snap like that, Amy.
What is that?
Fucking wish.com?
It was one of my backups.
It's a little lighter to carry around.
I didn't think I needed it.
Well, lucky for you, I'm a detective and I dabble as a mechanic.
The hammer's made of fucking wood, Tails.
Let me see both pieces of the hammer.
There's no way metal snaps like that.
No way.
That was a wood snap.
Just tighten things here.
A little elbow grease there.
And... fixed.
Tails!
Thank you!
He's a carpenter's son.
He is.
They're all squeaky hammers?
How the fuck does plastic snap like...
That still doesn't mean I'm a mechanic!
It's plastic!
Classic way.
Classic wood mechanic.
According to my calculations, if you hit the shelf right here, it could do the trick.
Alright!
Stand back!
The shelf completely shattered!
Incredible!
That was a fucking squeaky toy.
Who the fuck said it was?
I said it was a squeaky toy.
I said it was a squeaky toy earlier.
She fucking destroyed the shelf!
No squeaky toy can do that!
We did it!
We're free!
Property damage.
Great job, Amy!
Let's get out of here!
It's super expensive.
It's squeak, but it's metal.
But it squeaks.
Wait!
Is that...
Sonic!
Oh my god!
Who could have done such a thing?
It can't be!
I can't believe Sonic the Hedgehog died in the murder of Sonic the Hedgehog!
Who would have thought?
It can't be!
Sonic!
He's gone!
No!
Someone murdered my darling Sonic!
Looks like the game's begun!
I'm finding out who did this once at once!
Why is she so happy?
Amy, wait!
I wanna figure out who did this!
Wait for me!
Wait, what a whirlwind.
I'm exhausted already.
That was really convincing, Sonic.
Yeah, Sonic!
You can stop now!
Sonic?
Hey, Sonic!
You can get up!
They're gone now!
Sonic?
He's alive!
Body...
Gnome...
Can't...
Move...
Oh my god, what if it's Eggman?
What if it was Eggman all along?
Like the fucking... secret murderer?
What are you saying?
I don't understand!
I just...
need to...
rest...
Sonic?
SONIC!
Is he actually hurt?
Huh?
Man, he can't move.
Is he actually hurt?
He's not moving.
Are those...
coins on him genuine?
My hands on his wrist...
I don't sense a pause!
My god!
Where did that voice come from?
Oh my god!
There's no pause!
Sonic, talk to me!
Am I...
Am I doing this right?
What in the world is going on?
Is this part of the murder mystery?
Or...
Is this serious?
Sonic!
SONIC!
Oh no...
I feel myself panicking!
This is the most accurate way to kill me!
I've seen depictions of panic attacks in an animated game!
Calm down!
Don't give me a PSP tube!
What do I do?
Oh, I need you to do...
everything in your power...
to make sure...
our paying guests are well taken care of.
Understood?
Those guests are incredibly...
renowned.
Which means they must be remarkably rich!
You know...
MAKA!
So I leave their care to you...
Dokimedo FPSB Tube.
My favorite employee.
My only employee.
Surely you won't let me down...
on this last ride.
It's my first day!
I need to catch up to Amy and Tails...
and get to work.
I'm going to the bottom of this...
even though this is part of the game.
I just can't risk it.
I'll keep everyone safe...
conductor.
You'll see.
I just need to feed Sonic the rings!
I just need to force feed...
I'm sorry!
I just need to force feed him the rings!
Alright, here we go.
Fudge Top, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
He's definitely not...
Oh my god, we've...
Guys, we made it!
We finally got through the tutorial!
It only took one hour!
We fucking did it!
Tutorial done.
Woah, look at this place.
Tails.
Tails seems like the most competent one.
Hey Tails, where were you?
Where are you?
Jokey made of FPSVTube!
I'm over here!
I think Amy's already gone on ahead.
It seems she's really excited.
I bet you if there was like...
It was like the Walking Dead...
where like, oh, X amount of people chose like...
this route...
A or B or something...
I would not be surprised in the maturity...
of the people, pigtails.
It seems she's really excited.
Did you need something from me?
Uh, yeah.
Just a question really.
How do I put this?
What if Sonic is actually hurt?
Just force feed him rings.
He'll never be hurt.
He's laughing.
Sonic doesn't go down so easily.
He's on a train full of his friends.
Nothing would actually happen to him.
It's a mystery for Amy.
You have nothing to worry about.
Promise.
Plus...
Sonic likes to nap in a lot of strange spots.
He's fine.
It's making a lot of sense.
But I can't shake what...
Sonic said to me.
Is this really part of the murder mystery game?
Or is there something deeper...
happening?
I need more evidence to figure out what's going on.
Okay.
It's my job.
Wait.
Yeah.
I'm gonna let him know it's my job so he'll tip me.
It's my job to keep an eye on you.
The train rules say I gotta stay and watch after everyone.
You just won't hang out with me.
You just wanna hang out with me.
Don't ya?
I can see it in your eyes.
I mean you picked me over Amy.
How is everyone great at reading people but me?
As I said...
The best detectives...
have sidekicks.
So I'm happy to have you.
If you ever catch me looking glum though...
Just know it's because...
Where's my lawyer card?
Oh my god.
The last guy to work...
The last guy to work a case with me...
ditched our practice to join the evil Dr. Iggy.
Not a proper detective without baggage.
This is true.
Yeah.
Oh shit.
Okay.
Guys, I need you guys to know...
I can't do accents.
Especially country.
Okay, wait.
You vomit.
What are you doing in my salon?
Sorry.
I'm not doing country accents.
What are you doing...
What are you all doing in my salon?
He's trying so hard to stay in character.
Knuckles!
We're trying to figure out who murdered Sonic!
I can...
Okay.
I can see that...
Amy moseyed through...
and told me all about it.
Enough of that.
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
Enough of that.
I wonder how long he kept that voice up for Amy.
We were wondering if you could tell us what you were up to...
before the murder.
Anything to help us establish your alibi.
And...
Nope.
I have nothing to tell...
either of you.
Leave me alone.
He's sweating!
Analysis!
He is obviously agitated...
about something.
But why take it out on us?
It's him.
He's the murderer.
Amy was the red herring.
He's the actual murderer.
I know better than to argue with Knuckles.
So it seems we're on our own.
Dokimedo FPS Vtube.
We need to figure out what Knuckles...
was up to while we were all apart.
Let's investigate for clues...
and then...
interrogate.
Right!
Let's do it!
Okay.
He's obviously...
He played video games and then smashed it.
Clearly won't be able to give the game...
Super Monkey Ball a try.
Do we think it broke when the train...
sped up?
The damages...
look more to be caused from...
punches?
Who could it... Oh, I wonder who?
Could it be the Echidna?
That has a name...
Whose name is based on his fucking hands?
No.
Whose entire fucking super power is punching?
Nah.
Probably not.
What are you two looking at me for?
Smashed Arcade...
is added to your...
inventory.
No fucking...
way.
No fucking way.
Alright, let's talk to the head.
The robotic arms here are really...
helpful.
Mmm.
Hahaha.
What's the arm doing to my hair?
He fixed it up a bit!
That's incredible!
What interesting...
tech.
Uh oh.
Should I fear for my job a little bit?
How well can it microwave?
What's this?
Decent cash...
reward for finding this robot.
Maybe I'll keep an eye out.
Ooh, I need that.
Poor...
Omochao.
Hate to see them like this.
What'd they do?
Medical Mount...
What?
Interesting.
Wait, what the fuck did they do?
What the fuck?
Alright.
Oh.
Dokimedo FPS VTube.
This is...
interesting.
What is?
It's just a few...
used cups.
Sure.
But why are there...
three...
knuckles.
You know what they say about...
your kidness.
Ugh!
Um...
Knuckles was really...
thirsty.
Dokimedo FPS VTube.
This one has a lipstick...
on the rim!
That's not...
Knuckles' color at all!
Wait, he wears...
lipstick?
Someone else...
must have been here.
We should log in.
Rouge!
Oh, knuckles!
You sly...
dog!
I think we have enough clues.
Knuckles!
What are you...
doing with Rouge the cat?
Oh, wait, no.
Wait, Rouge the bat?
What?
Bat, cat...
same thing.
Bats are basically flying cats.
Okay.
I thought I told you...
to leave me alone.
I like your hat.
Oh!
Guys!
I'm getting...
better at Rizzing, people.
I told...
you, chat!
I told you I'm getting better...
at Rizzing!
Knuckles!
Are you...
blushing?
I said...
leave me alone.
Doesn't look like he's...
used to being...
complimented.
Jonesy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I can't believe Doki murdered...
Sonic for his passport.
Did you just adjust...
your hat a bit so...
we could see it...
better?
I said...
leave!
Alright, can I take...
your order?
Hm.
Not...
hungry.
Well, yeah...
alright.
Just let me know, won't ya?
Don't tell the robot I wanna keep...
my job.
Sure.
Like a butler of sorts.
Right?
Come on, DokiMatoFPSV2.
You're not a butler.
Tell him that.
Yeah, like a butler.
Cause I'm a little bitch.
Excellent.
Thank you, butler.
Dang it!
Oh shit, wait.
He doesn't wanna talk to me.
Alright.
Start the interrogation.
Objection!
Knuckles.
DokiMatoFPSV2.
And I need to determine what you...
were doing during the hour the murder...
took place.
I already told you.
Buzz off!
You're not getting anything out of me.
Thank you, butler.
We don't need to say much.
What happened here is pretty obvious.
Hm.
Wait.
It is?
We have evidence too.
We do?
DokiMatoFPSV2.
Just take a good...
look at our inventory.
Okay.
I hope we're gonna grab more evidence.
Because having two evidence...
tells...
tells the entire story.
And like, I really just need...
It's like a 50-50 on the order of the evidence.
What was distracting Knuckles...
during the time Sonic was murdered?
His little...
date.
Yeah.
Wait.
What?
Wrong choice.
DokiMatoFPSV2.
Let's try again.
Wait.
I lost the 50-50 guys.
Just like Doki Day.
I lost the 50-50.
Okay.
The smashed arcade.
The arcade machine?
Ha!
What makes you think I touched it?
Think!
Oh no.
Okay.
Guys, I'm thinking.
Guys...
I'm thinking.
God, I'm thinking so hard right now.
Oh my god.
You can see my brain.
Nice.
I did it.
As long as I don't send any spikes.
Oh my god.
Where's the fucking light bulb?
I did it!
I think!
This isn't a tough one, Knuckles.
Knuckles.
You clearly touched the arcade machine because...
The arcade...
Okay.
Your hair was filed at the scene.
Wait.
I wanna see this.
You mean fur?
Fur?
You mean spines?
Doesn't matter.
Cause it seems I'm wrong here.
Knuckles, you clearly touched the arcade machine because...
The arcade machine cabinet is covered in punches!
Take that!
What evidence do you have?
That the damages are punches!
Hmm...
What are y'all staring at my hands for?
My...
Nipple hands...
Do you guys know that famous, like...
Sonic the Hedgehog comic?
Regarding Knuckles' like...
Nipple hands?
And then the...
The creator of that Sonic comic...
Became like an official...
Artist for the official Sonic comics?
Did you guys kn...
Did you guys know that?
A little fun fact for you...
Um...
I don't think the official Sonic channel...
Would like...
Vouch for me though.
Knuckles, you clearly destroyed the arcade machine.
But why?
I needed a punching bag.
And none were available to me.
Just a sudden urge to punch?
Huh?
I vouch!
See?
What I told you!
It was real!
He vouches!
It's real!
I believe repairing the arcade machine...
Will give us our answer.
How would you?
I'm on it!
Tokimato FPS VTube!
Distract Knuckles!
While I fix Super Monkey Ball!
Bring it on!
Oh shit!
Don't worry.
Let me pull up my fucking...
Dream gear real quick.
Sorry Knuckles.
I can't pause the video game.
This is...
This is more important...
Than an actual fight.
Alright, here we go.
Nice.
Dodged.
Easy!
Oh my god.
So fucking easy.
Pink Doki Pink!
The arcade machine is fixed!
No!
Don't look at the score!
Quick!
Look at the scores!
I'm pulling it up now!
Okay, what does that...
Oh my gosh.
By one point.
Oh my god.
Noob.
Wait, does that...
Oh okay, it says bread.
Okay.
Okay, what does this tell us?
Nothing obviously.
It tells us something massive!
Look at the name at the top of the list!
It's Vector!
He's supposed to be in the...
Library...
He's like, hey do you remember where Vector is?
Do you remember?
If you don't remember, don't worry.
It's in bolded red letters.
It's supposed to be in...
The library car!
You just got Vectored.
Oh yeah!
The picture is beginning to be painted here.
You competed with Vector to see who could get the highest score.
And Vector beat you!
Mmm...
And in frustration, you destroyed the arcade cabinet!
Aaaaaaah.
He is punching the air in frustration.
You are guessing.
Where is your proof?
Where is your evidence?
Vector is a common name.
Prove to me he was here.
NOW!
Okay, I am thinking.
I don't know, there's like... wait but who's... I guess it was like Rouge, Vector...
Oh my god, they're not playing the game, seriously!
It's Amy's birthday!
Why are they not taking care of... oh shit, I'm sorry, I got distracted.
Why are they not taking her birthday seriously?
I just barely made it, holy fuck.
Maybe I should put on journalist mode.
Now, looking made of FPSV tube, what proves Vector was here with Knuckles?
Okay, I mean, I have two evidence, like what would my other evidence be?
It's process of elimination.
No!
I thought it was strange there was more than one cup sitting next to you.
Wow, you were supposed to be participating in the murder mystery game for Amy's birthday!
You and Vector enjoyed some drinks playing arcade!
It's... I'm... it's not like... it's not, I wasn't.
There was a woman there too.
Don't tell Amy.
I think we're on the right track here.
It's as you say, Vector popped in at the top of the hour.
Wanting to play the arcade machine with me.
We went back and forth, trying to figure the game out.
But when we did, we competed for the high score.
When he defeated me, I destroyed the machine.
No proof of his win.
Jesus Christ, man.
I was trying to fix the arcade cabinet before you two came in.
Honest.
I didn't want to be caught.
And that's my story.
An alibi.
I've already told an unbridged version of this to Amy.
Wait, then why...
Okay, if he told this version to Amy, why didn't he tell us?
Like, he already got caught.
Knuckles, you're just fucking stupid.
You already got caught!
Why were you like trying to hide it?
Whoa, this friend group...
Has a lot of pride issues.
I mean, there's a lot of issues in Sonic the Fandom.
That explains one of the used cups.
But...
What is a cup with a lipstick mark?
Hmm...
I don't want people to know...
That there was a woman here too.
Who was in here too.
Nevermind, I'm okay with saying it.
Hahahaha!
It's inconsequential.
Not worth mentioning.
So you searched around for something.
But failed.
Made fun of her again.
And left.
I'm nauseous, that one.
But...
You offered a drink, apparently?
Listen...
I don't know why she showed up.
And I told you everything that happened before the train sped up.
Are you not satisfied?
Will you two relent?
Hmm...
I'm understanding the scenario.
Vector visited to play games.
Rouge couldn't find something and left.
Then Knuckles destroyed the machine.
That all makes sense to me.
Thank you for answering so many of our quest...
Actually...
That's not everything.
Hahaha!
Is it Knuckles?
Wait, there's more?
He's clearly innocent.
Huh?
Hmm?
He's sweating!
Wait, there is more!
I wanna step back to something I noticed.
One more name on the high score list.
Doesn't make sense.
Wait, what?
I just remembered bread.
Dokimedo FPS VTube.
Can you take a look one more time?
An odd name on the high score list.
What is Tails talking about?
There's more?
Ultim?
Where's Ultim?
Is it Ultim?
Cause like all of this is food.
And then there's Ultim.
Ultimate?
All the names...
Yeah!
All the other names...
have food theme.
But this one...
Who here goes by Ultim?
Who the fuck is Ultim?
You may not know Dokimedo FPS VTube.
But there is someone here...
that goes by that title.
The ultimate life form.
Oh!
Truly...
The most edgy one out there.
There's really someone here.
I told you.
I'm just trying to be immersive chat.
I'm just trying to be immersive.
Okay?
I'm role playing as my Sonic OC.
There's really someone here that goes by that?
Also he's fucking...
Bro!
You can't...
How are you in the ultimate life form when you suck at video games?
Nothing sneaks by you, does it bud?
Vector and I were struggling so much with the game.
But then...
Shadow dropped by.
So...
Shadow is here too?
We're not taking seriously of Amy's fucking birthday party!
What are you doing outside of your carts?
He taught us the game and was the first to get his name on the scoreboard.
Vector and I then fought to be Shadow's score.
They're both very annoying.
We only meanly had to compete, huh?
He gave me this before he left!
What did he give?
A key?
Where did Shadow go to?
What was Shadow's cart?
Shadow told me to lock the door.
And to not open it for anyone.
Then...
He left.
When Vector was leaving...
I locked the door behind him.
Saw no one else after locking the door.
That is pretty sus.
He did it!
Knuckles and Amy were the red heron!
It was Shadow!
That's the honest truth.
So when Amy came through here not too long ago...
Did you open the door for her?
It was Shadow!
I knew it!
I knew it was Shadow!
No...
I think she has some sort of key too.
That's right.
The conductor gave her that special birthday key.
Well...
I have a lot of questions.
What happened in the library that caused Vector to come here?
Why is Shadow locked in doors?
And what was Rouge searching for?
I don't know.
They didn't tell me.
Even though I asked with that cowboy accent.
Y'all...
You're gonna have to find them and ask them yourself.
We did it!
We fucking did it!
We solved the mystery!
That is not Shadow...
No sorry.
Not Knuckles.
As of right now, I believe your story Knuckles.
We'll only know for sure when we confirm things with Vector.
Fair enough.
The library is in the next car.
I'll open the lock for you.
Give whatever KO'd Sonic an earful for me, Detective Tails and Butler.
I liked it better when he wasn't talking to us.
Will do, Sheriff!
Come on, Doki-Mato FPS VTube!
Let's head to the library!
But we gotta knock first so they can, you know...
In case we're interrupting anything.
This is way more exciting than microwaving chili dogs.
Doki-Mato FPS VTuber!
Coming!
Alright, let's go.
Knock knock!
Ready to mosey down on the next car.
Oh wait.
There's something in the trash can?
Okay, what's in the trash can?
Something's always hidden in the trash.
Let's check there.
Sadly, this one's empty as well.
Liars!
It's only a matter of time, Tails.
Have faith.
You're liars!
There was nothing in the trash can!
It's as they say.
One man's trash is another man's treasure.
Haha!
I think Tails is ignoring me.
Wait, try.
Trust.
Okay.
It's only...
Alright, we're gonna keep pressing.
It's empty!
What do you mean?
It's still empty!
Wait, is there an extra trash can?
No!
This one's empty!
Trust the system?
Okay, how many times do I have to press the fucking trash can?
Oh, they mean the next car.
Okay.
Alright.
You got it, partner.
Here we go.
Onwards!
Whoa.
The library.
Hang in there.
The library car.
This is a big ass fucking car.
This does not feel accurate to like the saloon back then.
This is wider than the saloon.
Oh, this stuff's getting heavy.
I'll dump what I don't need.
Everyone's favorite journalist reporter.
Amy Rose is hot on the scoop.
I'm heading out.
You've been fabulously helpful.
Already?
Before you go, Espio and I wanted to give you your presents.
My presents?
You're both too sweet.
Thank you.
Victor.
It seems we have more guests.
We have company.
Amy!
There you are.
Are you found any leads yet?
No, she doesn't have to join us.
It's okay.
She doesn't have to join us.
We don't want too many customers.
Cook's in the kitchen.
Oh?
The detective pair needs help from the birthday.
This is exactly why you're not joining us, Amy.
This is...
She knows everyone's allowed to be this sassy on their birthday.
This tip is just too juicy to ignore.
I'll see you all around.
Don't worry, Sonic.
I'll be the one to avenge you and quick.
But how are you going to leave?
The door to the next car is locked.
You doubt the birthday girl?
I have the journalist mode key.
Right, right.
The birthday girl gets journalist mode.
Of course.
It's a birthday privilege.
I'll solve the case before anyone else.
Bye!
Amy may be hasty, but she's thorough.
Now, what are you two doing here?
Looking mighty suspicious, I say.
Wait, does that mean like the key that Knuckles has only works for like one car?
So like...
Oh, because it's not the master key.
It's like in the...
Wait, then how did Shadow get the fucking...
I fucking knew it was Shadow.
How the fuck did Shadow grab the saloon car key?
I'm the detective.
And so I can be the murderer.
I knew it was Tails.
I knew it.
Knuckles, uh, Vector, uh...
Knuckles, Shadow, and Amy were red herons.
I knew it.
It was Tails all along.
And I'm...
Uh...
Oh, he's the lock spy!
I forgot he's the lock spy.
I forgot he's the lock smith.
Oh yeah, he had a job.
Sorry.
The ultimate life form actually has a...
Imagine being the ultimate life form and still having a job...
Having to get a job.
Um, I'm here to ask if anybody's hungry.
Starved!
I'll kill you for a chicken parmesan right about now.
Maybe kill isn't the right language to use right now.
Sonic's dead.
Um, Vector the butcher.
I'm licensed to handle raw meat.
Huh.
That's right.
And I'm Espio the poet.
Ah, poetry.
A resident message from poet to reader.
Meant to challenge our delicate perspective with the most...
Rhythmic of poise.
Fucking...
NERD!
Can I hear some?
Sure.
Oh my god, he's a poser!
Teardrops in the spring.
Can you hear me sing?
La la la la dee dee dee dee.
Oh my god, that was so beautiful.
That was so beautiful, guys.
Oh my god.
Beautiful.
Was that it?
I have more if you like.
Cherry blossoms in the spring.
I'm satisfied now, thanks.
I can't believe it.
Why did you interrupt him?
It was going so well.
I'm blue da ba dee ba da da.
At least he's rhyming, I suppose.
I cry every time.
It was like a haiku, but like with more syllables.
It was almost like a haiku, guys.
It was just like, you know, it might be just like a little bit more syllables than it should be.
But it was almost like a haiku.
Tokimedo, FPSVTube.
And I am here to establish both of your alibis.
It's snowing on Mt.
Fuji.
Can you walk us through what happened after Amy...
had everyone leave the dining car?
Oh sure, it's simple.
We just explain to Amy, actually.
Alright.
Okay, so after this, we gotta talk through this.
And then we gotta talk to Shadow.
And then we solve the mystery.
When we're all sent off, it's always like it has to be like the last person.
And I knew it was Shadow.
Everybody else were red herrings.
Shadow and Sonic all pass through this library car.
Where Amy told me...
and Espio to stay.
I promptly picked up a book off the shelf...
and made myself comfortable.
Vector got bored.
So he left to see what Knuckles was up to in the saloon car.
Yup.
Where was Rouge?
We happened to see her...
We happened to see her lipstick stain on a cup after saloon car.
Rouge came over to the library car.
Seemingly to look for something.
Maybe money?
I mean she's always looking for money, right?
Then she went to search the saloon car.
She came back shortly after.
We heard her shout, No way!
At the brochure stand over there.
But she left back to the casino car before Shadow came through and locked the door.
It has to be like some sort of money thing.
Like that's the only thing that gets like Rouge going.
It's always like money related.
Um...
After all, she's a thief.
Unlike me, who's also a thief.
Wonder what she found.
She's obviously been on the hunt for... something.
After Rouge left, Shadow walked through the casino car.
Then entered the library car and locked the door behind him.
More importantly...
Why has Shadow been lock...
Yeah!
Why have you been locking doors?
What is he trying to hide?
Huh?
Shadow walked through the library car to the saloon car where Knuckles and I were playing games.
He insisted on showing us at Super Monkey Ball.
I got so engrossed by the rolling monkey action, I hardly noticed when Shadow left the saloon car.
I guess he walked through the library car to the casino car again locking the door behind him.
Then returned to the lounge car where he was meant to be stationed.
When Vector came back, we realized Knuckles locked the door to the saloon car.
We were stuck in the library car.
Yes, because you're supposed to be stationed at your cars.
You're not...
Are you not taking this game seriously?
Shadow took the game seriously.
It's Amy's birthday.
That's when the train sped up.
We were worried about the bookshelves falling on us.
But we got through it all right.
We sat trapped here until Amy arrived, asking questions.
She's the one that told us someone murdered Sonic.
And yeah, that's all that happened.
I mean, they don't look like they're hiding anything.
Hmm...
With all these locked doors...
It seems Vector and Espio couldn't have left the library car.
Or the saloon car.
Thank you both for your cooperation.
We're just gonna peek around and we'll return with any questions.
If you return with any...
Me...
I'll chop it up for ya.
And if you like to be serenaded with a poem...
I've got you covered.
Thanks guys.
Their alibi seems solid enough.
But we should still search for clues.
What we're looking for is evidence that proves what they're saying.
It's true!
We need to confirm Vector's reason for leaving his post.
And determine if Espio was actually in the library car.
Reading.
A tall task.
But we can do it.
Let's get to the bottom of this, Tails.
Absolutely!
Yay!
Okay, what were the brochures?
I mean, there's books everywhere.
So obviously they've been reading, right?
Oh yeah, where's the trash can?
Something's always hidden in the trash can.
Let's check it there.
I hate to say it, but there's nothing here.
I really thought there'd be something there.
No quimedo, FPSVTube.
Are you sad there was nothing in the trash can?
No.
I got one guide.
I'm sure there'll be something hidden in the next trash can.
Wait.
It's in the next one, I swear.
I won't get one guide again.
You really think so?
Yeah.
We just gotta stay optimistic.
Okay.
There's no way we get one guide again.
Right, Tails?
Trust the stream.
Doki made a FPSVTube.
You're pretty unconventional.
But I like that.
Was that supposed to be a compliment?
All right.
Anyway...
Assume like... what were she looking at the brochures?
Brochures!
There are travel destination ideas here.
Like amusement parks, caverns, hotels, restaurants!
Oh!
Tokimeto FPS VTube!
Look at this!
There's a couple maps here.
Wait, of what?
This is like literally...
It's like... it's a singular line.
You go up or down.
This seems to be a map of the library car.
The books are organized by genres.
What's your list here?
I love a good overhead map.
Let's take it!
Okay.
Should we take this brochure about cave too?
Look!
There's stalactites.
Nah!
Leave it!
Yeah, that's fair.
Wait, but what was the brochure that Rouge was looking at?
Nobody shares my brochure.
My fondness for caves.
Are they caves?
I mean, that makes sense actually.
Well, this is like...
scarily accurate.
To my Sonic OC.
I wish we had time to pick them up.
I sadly have no interest in picking up these books.
A lot of these were knocked out by the trains speeding up.
But Rouge pulled a lot of these out searching for something.
What's she searching for?
What?
Reckless behavior!
I feel sorry for the poor books.
The spines are creasing.
They're opening too far.
This kid feels empathy for everything.
Wait.
What could it be?
That could like, disprove what they're saying.
Like, do I look at the books?
Wow.
I wish I could stop and look at all these books.
But Sonic needs me.
No time to rest.
Alright, let's move on then.
I mean, a little peek wouldn't hurt.
He's scavenging through all the books a little excitedly.
He's like a kid in a candy shop.
Or in this case, a genius in a train library.
That's odd.
I know some books have fallen out on the floor and everything.
But...
Every book on these shelves...
is in alphabetical order.
But this one...
Ohhhh.
How the fuck did you notice that?
Who looks at the alphabetical...
Oh my god.
What a fucking nerd.
This is...
This is why you're not hanging out with other kids, Tails.
This is why you're hanging out with adults.
It's the user guide to the Mirage Express.
The train we're currently on.
Do you think someone found it on the ground and put it back?
It is interesting.
Okay, that's mean.
Where are your children friends?
Where are your friends at your age, Tails?
Let's make a note of this.
Mirage Express manual is added to your inventory.
Alright.
We got the...
Oh, wait.
What?
Why is there another book?
What's this bright red book?
Oh, yuck.
This reeks of the evil sign.
Wait, what?
Dr. Eggman?
What is this written by Dr. Eggman?
I mean, he is a doctor.
Is he a real doctor?
I remember someone said that he's not a real doctor.
And his name...
He's like impersonating.
Yep.
This is Dr. Eggman's autobiography and recipe book.
He is?
He's a real doctor?
He has a PhD?
What kind of recipes?
Who cares?
I wouldn't trust any book.
He has a PhD, Tails.
What do you have?
You're not Dr. Tails?
It's weird this is even here.
Do you even have a master's degree?
Do you have a license to be performing mechanical things?
Did you even went to trade school?
Maybe people just appreciate an omelet.
You may not be wrong.
Okay.
Oh, the seat?
No.
What would...
I don't feel like...
Is there anything else?
Okay.
What other fucking...
Oh, wait.
Maybe the lights?
Oh, okay.
Never mind.
Check out our book club.
On the train?
Book of the month.
Gone gal.
That's nice.
What?
What can I...
Oh, wait.
Do I have...
Do I have all the evidence?
Okay.
Let's see.
This is that.
And then...
Boop, boop, boop, boop.
Huh.
I don't have all the evidence yet.
The cherry tree?
So, these are pretty obvious.
Let's take a look at that.
That just looks pretty cool.
No,
I want...
Oh my God!
Oh, tsk.
Oh, it's supposed to be...
WOOOAAHHH!
Ooh, that was tough.
Overall, I really like it.
It's just...
It's low like in injangando.
I'm in the first row.
I'm a murderer.
Ruined my nap time.
That is a bit concerning.
Oh, poor thing.
That arm is really struggling cleaning up this car.
To be fair, I wouldn't want to clean up all this mess either.
Let's just leave it alone and do its thing.
Yeah, probably for the best.
What?
I feel like I looked at all the evidence except for hang in there, but I'm pretty sure that's not evidence.
A globe of our marvelous planet!
I haven't traveled around much.
The islands are fun and all, but I love to visit some of the counties.
They're a lot of fun, honestly.
Plenty of the wonderful people and shops.
The food can't be beat either.
Sounds perfect for a vacation.
The conductor was talking about Spagonia.
Have you ever been there?
I have actually!
If you're ever visiting, be sure to stop at the university and say hi to Professor Picker!
That'll tell you everything about the area and make one scrumptious sandwich!
I'll keep that in mind.
Thanks!
This group knows everyone and has been everywhere, haven't they?
Yeah, they're fucking rich!
DokiMatoFPSVTube, you're just a train boy.
You barely earn minimum wage.
Alright, let's see.
I feel like I talked to everything except for this.
I swear to God, this cannot be.
Let me talk to Vector.
Do you bring me any meat to chop?
I may be a butcher.
But they confiscated my meat cleaver before getting on the train.
Did you actually try to bring a knife on the train?
I mean, I did.
Stop, stop.
I'm a man of authenticity.
Because with a knife, I'm just a chef.
And a catcher.
I'm a chef's stained apron.
Not a butcher.
I think they had a knife on you.
We definitely think you're the murderer.
Um...
Except for me.
But what if I hit the knife?
Hehehehe.
You know, I'm not the biggest fan of that line of thought.
Alright, can I start my interrogation now?
I don't think we have enough evidence yet.
Why don't we take a look... a little more... look around.
Wait, then what the fuck?
What the fuck am I missing?
I looked at these books.
I looked at that book.
I looked at the table.
I looked at those books.
Is there more books that I forgot?
The door?
Hmm...
Shadow supposedly walked through the library door before going to the saloon car.
Oh my god, I was supposed to look at the door?
When Shadow left the library car, he locked this door on his way out.
There's gotta be a reason he's doing this.
Should we make a note of it?
Hmm... I do believe we should.
Shadow's lock is added to your inventory.
I think we found enough clues.
It was the first time we found a lock.
We're going to have to find a door.
Let's go interrogate Vector.
I have no idea.
I don't know.
I don't know what the reasoning is.
Guys, I don't even know.
I'm going to have to have the game to handhold me.
I don't know what we figured out.
All right, start interrogation.
So the two of us, you don't believe us?
It's not that I don't trust either of you.
But...
I wouldn't be a proper detective.
Oh, that's easy.
I got bored.
Hahaha!
That's the thing!
Why would you put the butcher in the library?
It doesn't make sense, Amy!
Amy!
This is not immersive!
Why is he in the library?
Unless he's getting some meat.
Hahaha!
What?
I wasn't interested... Oh, damn.
Damn.
That sucks, man.
Hahaha!
I was entertaining him enough, it seems.
Vector enjoys being social.
Damn.
Just no chemistry, huh?
Just no chemistry.
Hahaha!
Plus, we were instructed to mingle.
I remembered the arcade machine in the saloon car.
So I figured I'd go check it out.
This seems to line up with the information we gathered with Knuckles.
That brings our attention to you, SBO.
Woosh entered the library car, found something, and then left.
You said you immediately started reading.
But were you actually reading the entire time you were in the library car?
Hmm... Of course he was!
Huh?
Once SBO starts reading, he doesn't stop till it's done!
I've seen it happen!
Damn.
Simp.
It must have been a good read.
What was the book?
Hmm...
SBO doesn't owe you that, detective.
Where's the warrant?
Huh?
Hahaha!
I won't talk until my lawyer's here!
Let the man live!
What if it was...
Embarrassing!
What kind of things do you think I read?
If you won't talk, I have a hunch on what that book might be.
Hmm...
TokimedoFPSBTube, can you help me out?
Let's see.
I wonder if I have any evidence that's just a book.
Hahaha!
Guys, what book do you think SBO may have been reading?
Hmm...
I must have...
I wonder...
I wonder which one is a book.
Hahaha!
Hmm...
A manual?
You think SBO was reading instructions?
What argument could you possibly have to support this?
Think, Omno.
It's time to parkour.
Oh no.
There you go.
I like how it's like Sonic.
As like the...
Oh no, no.
Why did I jump?
Wait, what?
No!
I got confused!
I was like, that was a new mechanic that was introduced and I wasn't sure what was going on!
Okay.
Alright.
I figured it out.
I got confused.
They gave me a new mechanic.
And I wasn't prepared.
I didn't have time to actually register what it was.
But it's okay.
I'm a gamer.
I like how like my name is up there too.
Hahaha!
There are books scattered around the floor, sure.
But the remaining books on the shelves were all in alphabetical order.
All except this manual.
At least someone, at the very least, picked up the manual up and put it back in the incorrect place.
Dum-bum-bum!
Hmm...
This lack of attention to detail isn't normally like you, SPO!
Hey now!
I won't have you insulting my pal like this!
Calm down, Vector.
I know you, Miwa.
But I can handle myself.
Apologies, SPO.
A butcher and a poet.
Friendship can form anywhere.
That is indeed the book I was reading.
The Mirage Express Manual.
Trains are... okay.
Trains are cool.
I like trains.
In that case, we'd like to ask you a few questions about the manual.
Tokimedo FPSVTube, if you don't mind.
That's me!
Can you ask SPO questions?
I'll ask you some questions about the manual.
Just flip to a page and ask away.
Oh, I see.
Quiz SPO about the manual to prove he read it.
Which page should I quiz him on?
I don't fucking know.
362?
Um...
What efficient and extremely accurate technology was installed to assist and keep...
What is he like?
Does he like fucking...
Has like that type...
What is that, memory?
Photographing memory?
Like, what the fuck?
Keeping those trains spotless?
Oh my god!
Okay, this is like a random story.
But this reminds me of the time where like...
Um...
I...
I think it was like in middle school.
I was like chosen to do like some fucking like...
Uh...
Some like...
Academic tournament or something.
Where it was like separated by different subjects like psychology, math, reading, English and stuff like that.
And then like...
And like special subject.
And then I was selected to be on that team.
And it was like this like academic quiz.
So like you have to have like...
Like...
Multiple choice questions to answer, debate and uh...
Do not say nerd!
Writing an essay and you compete against like different type...
Different schools.
And then like...
I was studying for it.
And then um...
You know...
I was studying for it in like the bus ride to like uh...
The venue.
Like cause like I was like...
You know...
Getting some last minute study on.
And this kid like sat in the...
Okay I was also a kid.
But this kid like sat next to me.
And then he was like...
Oh you're doing...
You're like um...
Uh...
Brushing up?
And I was like...
Yeah I am.
And then he was like...
Give me a page.
And I was like...
What?
It was like...
Give me a page.
And I was like...
I was like...
Uh...
And I was like...
This page.
And then he read...
Word to word what it was on that page.
And then that was the day.
I realized I'm not special.
I was not special.
Not nerd enough.
There is always someone stronger.
Okay.
What efficient and extremely accurate technology...
Was installed to assist in keeping the train spotless.
Um...
Robot...
Okay.
And then like...
I tested him in various other pages.
And...
Yeah.
Needless to say...
I'm pretty sure that kid did really well.
Robotic arms.
During events...
They can perform a variety of tasks.
And are responsible for cleaning up the trash.
And...
Messes afterwards.
He was the bigger nerd.
I remember the conductor saying that the train can clean itself.
Though...
I have a feeling the train company just didn't want to hire any janitors.
I mean like...
Why would you need to hire janitors when literally the train does it for you?
Like...
It doesn't even get paid.
Robots don't need to get paid because they don't have rights.
The robotic arms can also detect weapons or explosive beams brought onto the...
Onto the...
Onto the train.
Ensuring passenger safety.
Seems like SPO A stack question.
Jokey made of FPSV tube.
Hit him with another one.
Oh my god.
We know.
We know already.
We don't need to hit him with another one.
Oh my god.
Tails.
He definitely knows what he's talking about.
I'm giving him literally a random fucking page.
What is a Mirage Express cancellation policy?
No refunds.
And you will be charged a no refund.
No show fee.
This does not apply if you're over the age of 65.
Gee.
The person who made this rule must have been over 65.
He was like 66.
Last one.
Jokey made of FPSV tube.
Let's see if SPO can go three up for three.
Cut.
After the first one it should be okay, Tess.
Oh my god.
Don't be jealous that he's a bigger fucking nerd than you are.
Like...
Alright, 402.
What was implemented to support the conductor duties and his general train obligation?
An intelligent data processing system.
It works in tandem with the conductor to ensure smooth travel for guests.
I remember this.
The train has an autopilot, but it can't access its full suite of capabilities without the conductor present.
Now, that passed your little test.
No.
No, I don't want to keep going.
Yes.
Totally.
It's wild you're able to retain all this information so quickly.
A poet's brain is often surprising.
I don't know if I'd be bragging about that.
Clearly read the manual.
Those answers feel far too specific to me.
Oh my god.
Tails.
Just accept it.
He's a bigger nerd than you.
Oh my god.
Tails.
And you both had the nerve to question my buddy like that.
Don't we want to be supportive folks who read?
You don't even read, Vector.
You have to admit though, reading the entire time a murder occurred does sound a bit suspicious, even if it's true.
We answered all my questions so calmly.
That's very impressive.
No, no.
I understand everyone's cautious attitudes.
Vector was the only one to see me reading after all.
My alibi is hard to substantiate despite being the truth.
Well, definitely read through the manual.
So I suppose we can...
Espio, is that true?
Vector was the only one to see you reading?
Yes.
That's correct.
Wait, what about Rouge?
Wait, Rouge see me read?
Frankly, I don't believe that can be true.
And we have evidence to back it up.
Doki made an FPSB2.
Wait, we do?
He always puts me on the spot.
We do?
Who else saw Espio reading?
I guess...
the map.
Oh, Shadow...
Wait, what about the menu?
Not sure what you're trying to say, that.
Don't waste my time.
But what if people are hungry?
Okay, Shadow's blog.
Shadow's blog?
Please, pray tell me.
What does that have to do with anything?
We're up, Doki made an FPSB2.
Let's get our arguments.
We're back in the tournament together!
Okay, are you also playing this little game while we're thinking too, Tez?
Do we both have any dream gear?
It's okay.
I figured it out.
Alright.
It's okay, I'm thinking right now.
Guys, this is what happens in my brain.
You guys are like, what is going on in that little tomato brain of hers?
This is what happens.
I'm playing a little Sonic game.
Oh my gosh, I'm doing so well.
Yay!
Oh my god, this is like longer than before.
Alright, nice.
I got 23 more.
Just like me.
This is how my brain works on Sonic.
I scored for long.
Crocs are natural gamers.
Espio said he saw Shadow enter the library car.
But, he's mentioned nothing about Shadow's return.
He only mentioned that Vector came back.
When Shadow left Knuckles and Vector in the saloon car, Espio was fully seated reading his book for a good while at that point.
We know Shadow had to walk back.
Back through the library car when he left the saloon car.
So, there's absolutely no way Shadow and Espio didn't notice one another on Shadow's return trip.
Oh!
He's cooking!
I mean, it was a simple slip up.
I was just fully immersed in my book.
That didn't notice Shadow.
Yep.
That's it.
When nerds attack each other.
Nerd fight!
You're telling me that sound of the door opening and locking wouldn't have caused you to look up?
Well, you see?
Take that!
I can sense desperation here.
Defending the argument that he was reading the entire time isn't easy.
So, if you didn't see Shadow returning from the saloon car, and lock all the doors, and at that moment, were you really in the library car at all?
How would Espio leave?
Shadow locked all the cars.
And no one saw Espio in the saloon car.
She went to the casino!
It's a mystery, my dear DokimedoFPSV.
Sorry.
It's a mystery, my dear DokimedoFPSVTube.
One that I would love for Espio to solve.
Oh my god!
He was gambling!
The biggest crime!
Are you even over 21 to gamble, Espio?
You gotta believe me.
That cool demeanor is vanishing.
I was so involved in my book, I didn't know Shadow passed through the library car.
Honest.
When Vector returned, he even had to tap me on the shoulder to get my attention.
Yeah.
I think I remember.
I think.
I think I remember doing that.
I must avenge my friend's death.
So I can ask you again, Espio.
If you weren't there for Shadow to see you reading, then how did you leave the library car?
I wasn't.
I didn't.
Why does this seem right to me?
Tails definitely feels like he's onto something.
But I don't see it.
Was Espio simply sitting, reading?
Or does he seem to have managed to not notice Shadow's return to the library car?
What should I do?
Join Tails.
You know what?
I'm going to be all in on Tails.
Join Tails.
No.
I can't interrupt Tails while he's onto something.
I'll let him continue this lying and questioning end.
A document of FPSVTube.
My fave.
Wait.
Does he get more and more, like.
Are these real memories or he just made up these memories at this point?
My fave, because I met him like one time.
My favorite and beloved employee.
Please.
It doesn't even feel like his actual, like made up flashback.
Protect the past.
Well done.
Passengers aboard this train.
They must be taken care of.
If you fail.
Oh, yeah.
The lawsuits will be torturous.
Don't sell out such an old feeble soul to get sued.
That's gonna be like I just met that guy.
How do I have so many flashbacks?
I have to make sure our guests are taken care of.
Oh my gosh.
I'm hearing voices.
I have to speak up.
Tails!
We have a piece of evidence that can answer all of our problems.
Alright, my fellow associate.
Lay it on me.
What piece of evidence shows Shadow and Espo couldn't have seen one another?
The map!
Look at the map!
This one because it's my last evidence!
Now, let's get my thoughts in order.
Alright, it's time to game.
Sorry.
Give me a sec.
I'm gaming real quick, Tails.
Don't worry.
Um...
When I'm finished gaming, I'll be able to answer your question.
Uh...
Just...
Just gotta finish gaming now.
Weee!
Oh my gosh.
Ooh.
This is gonna be risky.
Okay.
I got that.
Okay, I'm in.
I'm fucking in.
I don't have to worry now.
Weee!
I already got seventy- Oh!
Oh, that was scary.
I wasn't paying attention there.
It's okay.
We're set.
Yay!
I'm gaming.
Gotta work on those brain cells.
The library map?
I see!
See the exits?
They're right across from one another.
A straight path.
If Shadow walked down the straight path, there's a way Espo and Shadow couldn't have seen one- Wait, what?
Oh, I guess if he sat there.
Over here.
And then he goes down the straight path.
And then he goes this way.
Yeah, he just needs to sit on that one chair.
Or here.
No, no, here.
Looks like you have to point out exactly where on the map.
Map, map, map.
Uh, you mean...
Where could Espo have been for Shadow to not see him?
Oh, here!
Here.
Interesting.
That's where I was sit- Oh, I thought it was like Espio that not see him.
Okay, I thought he meant Espio!
Okay!
And then I read- Oh, where could he sit for Shadow to not see him.
Interesting.
That's where I was sitting reading my book.
Yeah, of course, that's exactly where.
I can second this!
When I returned from the saloon car, Espio was in the same spot.
I made him like- I made Vector like dumber and dumber the more I voiced him.
That confirms it then.
You see, Shadow and Espio couldn't have seen one another from this spot.
Because...
Book is in the way.
I can't believe I suck my neck out for you, Tez.
I can't believe it.
You fucking made an innocent chameleon cry.
I suck my neck for you, man!
I defended you!
There's no way Shadow could've seen Espio.
Or vice versa!
It makes a lot of sense why he never mentioned Shadow's return, Espio.
It's just no way you have seen him.
I can't believe I defended you!
I can't believe it isn't a proven guilty!
I apologize for losing my cool back there.
I felt like I was grasping despite telling the truth.
I'm glad y'all believe me now.
Your alibi isn't the most airtight, but I have no further points.
I'm sorry I gave you a trauma a little bit.
Thank you both for answering all our questions.
We did it!
Another pair of alibis!
Validated!
Yeah!
Who the fuck did it?
Too many locked doors to worry about.
I'm glad everything straight- Okay, I bet you nobody did anything and Sonic just got overdosed with like chili- chili dogs.
I bet you.
I swear.
Okay, um, quote me on this right now.
Nobody did anything and Sonic just ate too many chili dogs and passed out.
I'm exhausted.
I'm gonna crash here for a bit.
Those chairs are soooo comfy.
Likewise, I could use a breather.
Sadly, our work isn't done.
I have plenty of questions for Rouge and especially Chat.
What about Blaze?
No one ever said anything about Blaze.
Like I- I like how no one said- like she's so irrelevant...
That no one has said anything about Blaze or like Blaze has done anything at all.
At this point, I'm feeling pretty confident in our detective abilities.
We're really doing this.
Come on Dokimado FPSVTube.
Let's see what's next.
Coming!
Alright, let's leave.
Let's see.
Yeah, I'm ready to go.
The mystery cause.
Alright, is Amy gonna be in a casino?
Wait!
Oh my god!
He has a mustache!
I thought they were all children!
What the fuck?
Oh, this stuff is getting heavy.
I've dumped what I don't need.
Rouge!
There you are!
We have a lot of things to say to you!
We visited every train car in the city.
And everyone said they've seen you wandering about.
It's high time you told us why!
My, my.
Talk about a warm welcome.
Quick to a point.
Aren't ya darling?
I see you brought the microwave master with you.
M-M-M-Master?
Please don't let that be my legacy bro.
What the fuck?
People will kill for that.
Tails is right.
Pokes have brought you up a lot.
Care to explain?
Tell him, Rouge.
We're gonna need that help.
Oh my god, she actually has a role.
Oh my god, guys!
Blaze actually talks and has a role in this game.
Blaze?
Alright.
I've been hunting for a treasure.
Rumored to be stored here on the train.
I knew it!
I knew it was treasure.
It's always something.
It's always about money.
Treasure?
She didn't tell me about treasure in the interview.
Since I'm a part business tycoon, part purveyor of fine collectibles, I knew I had to find it.
Tell him what it is, Rouge.
Alright.
Well...
It's a... oh my god, a Faberg cake.
I don't understand those.
Like, people have actually spent like millions on Faberg eggs.
But like, I don't understand.
It's just like... it's just like a bedazzled egg.
Like... it's... it's just a fucking bedazzled egg.
Like, I don't understand.
Why are they so popular?
What are those?
What I said?
Eggs with like fucking jewelry on it.
Um... it's a really fucking fancy egg.
Wow, that sounds extravagant.
Please, don't tell me you accepted Amy's birthday invite only to find that egg.
Don't you care about Amy?
The girl that clearly has a lot of friends?
Sorry, Amy.
A woman can have multiple...
Multiple goals.
I gave Amy her birthday present already.
So everything's well taken care of.
Wait, is Blaise French?
She roped me in on the hunt immediately.
Okay, I can't do a French accent either.
Wee wee, she roped me.
Wee wee, mademoiselle.
She roped me in on the hunt immediately.
I stayed here while...
she searched the train cars for clues.
I deduced that the Faberg Chaos Eggs is here.
In this train car.
Locked in a safe.
Wait, so the treasure is real?
It's actually here?
And what did you manage to find, Rouge?
Well, why don't you both take a look?
Oh, it's like the blueprints.
I found the blueprints in the library car.
With the safe code written right on it.
The score of a lifetime.
The train's blueprints?
Please, Rouge, let us see that.
Uh-uh-uh.
Finders keepers.
Sweetheart.
There's a problem.
We need your assistance.
You want a child's help?
What kind of problem?
The elevator behind the security guard...
lead us right to the room...
holding the Faberg...
Chao Egg.
Oh, it says Chao.
I thought that...
I thought that says Chaos Egg.
I was like, damn.
I didn't realize they made Chaos Eggs.
Holy shit.
Oh my god, they...
They've been dancing.
They dazzle the fucking Chao Egg.
But we're not getting anywhere, darling.
With out the guards...
Bro!
It's a child!
Kick the Chao!
Throw...
Just throw...
Just pick it up and chuck it!
What is he gonna do?
Fight back?
Bro!
Fucking throw him in the ocean!
We need a plan to get that car...
To use the elevator...
And our...
Chance of success grows...
With everyone's help.
Who wants to help you steal the Faberge Chao egg?
Her lower card must be influencing her decisions here.
Either that, breaking the rules must be refreshing for the princess.
Do not kick the Chao.
Kick the Chao!
They become rare if you kick the Chao.
They turn into evil Chaos.
They're rare.
Stealing is for squares.
Damn, I'm so cool.
I think the only square here is you.
Microwave master.
I must admit, that wasn't the coolest thing I've...
I'm so cool!
So cool.
I heard someone say...
My cool and mysterious reputation is crumbling.
Alright, alright.
I'm in.
I'll help.
I'm help.
I'll be a square.
The women say I wasn't cool, so I got peer pressured.
I suppose it will be...
You know how it is when the Blaze and Dokimedo FPSVTube are in?
Okay, let's get that Faberg Chao egg!
That's the ticket.
Happy to have you both on the team.
Now, we must plan.
Oh my god, we're doing a heist.
It's heist time!
Oh boy, what have we gotten ourselves into?
Access to the Faberg Chao egg room is behind a locked elevator door.
Why would you agree with that, Rouge?
You have a gun!
Access the Faberge... okay.
I guess we don't... I don't attack the guard.
We distract... describe the guard?
Distract the guard?
What do we distract him by?
I guess we can like...
bribe?
Anyone have anything we can use for a bribe?
I have a pair of tweezers.
Here's a trading card!
I'm not giving you anything.
But you're a princess!
You have stuff!
You can just go back to your other dimension and ask like...
dad to buy you more things!
Maybe bribing isn't the way to go.
We have... oh my god.
But they're the easiest choices.
Bribing is the easiest choice.
Bribing is attacking!
Distract them.
Perfect!
We're all charming enough for that to work.
That was actually a really nice thing to say.
Doki Mato FPS B-Tube.
Is everything okay?
I've never seen you smile like that.
Oh my god!
I'm in!
Guys!
Until Sally the squirrel comes over.
Then... then... I'm sorry Rouge.
You're gonna get...
See?
I know my fucking Sonic lore!
I'm just like you guys!
Seems they don't know how to take a compliment.
Hey guys, Sally doesn't...
Wait.
Is she a squirrel?
I don't remember.
Wait.
Maybe I'm not in.
No, she is!
I'm fully committing.
She doesn't wear pants.
Chick buck squirrel!
I was half in.
I was half right.
Wait.
She isn't catting?
Is it because she doesn't wear pants?
But they don't...
Fucking Tails doesn't wear pants!
Alright.
If I'm gonna be in a casino, my poker face needs work.
Who's distracting the...
Rouge wore pants?
Look!
That's pants!
Who's distracting...
Well, obviously Rouge, right?
Rouge.
Of course I'll distract him.
Who can resist my venom and charms?
I'm not sure how to...
affect your charms beyond a chow.
Plus, your flight might prove useful.
I'm not sure you bring distraction makes sense.
Fair enough.
Let's think it over again.
Wait.
Who else is gonna be distracting?
Tails?
I mean, he's useless in everything else, right?
Sure, I could be the distraction!
I don't like the way you said that.
Okay!
Then Blaze!
Oh my god!
No, I really could do it!
Sorry buddy.
I think you'll be better off.
Okay, Blaze!
I don't know!
They're all distracting enough!
You can distract a guard, Blaze?
In my life, I've never let a single person down!
I won't falter.
Upgrade her voice.
Oh wait, she was stoic this entire time?
Oh fuck, okay.
Sorry, I gave her too much pressure.
I'm not a personality.
Her voice was so stoic, I have chills.
I guess...
I guess, yeah, she looks like Raven.
So, you're right.
She looks like Raven, so I should have fucking...
I should have known.
Well, I trust her.
Moving on...
What's the distraction?
Uhhhh...
Uh...
About their partner and kids...
Push a bunch of poker chips to the floor?
Okay, yeah.
I'll be like, Oh, Mr. Chow...
I'm so dumb...
The claw machine is stuck...
Excuse me!
Wait, there's no claw machine in the casino?
I'm not a distraction!
Let's continue the plan!
Sumimasen...
Mr. Chow...
The card distracted!
Rouge, how would you get the access card?
Okay, pick their pocket.
I'll snatch the access key, no problem.
The chow in uniform won't notice a thing.
Rouge, try not to take anything else from them.
If you can help it.
No promises.
The card obtained.
We need to get Blaze out of there.
Dokimedo, FPSVTube, what's your plan?
Um...
Push the security guard over.
I'm still not comfortable.
It's just a little push.
That chow is low to the ground.
It won't hurt them.
But...
What if they start crying?
It'd bring unwanted attention to us.
Was that accurate?
Was that accurate to Blaze?
Why does someone who cries so easily a security guard anyway?
Exactly!
Decent point.
Let's think of something else.
Fucking cowards!
You guys are cowards!
Alright.
Say there's a drink without a coaster.
Absolutely!
I can't think of anything worse!
Despicable.
I would never allow such a thing in my kingdom.
The guard will go running immediately.
I'm sure of it.
Great.
And with the guard distracted, we'll all head to the elevator.
And just like that, we all make it to the elevator.
We all make it to the elevator.
Inside we have...
I don't know.
Sing victory acapella?
Now that's a proper victory!
Oh no.
One last security measure we didn't account for.
Wait, what?
We missed the spouse route?
I'm pretty sure they're like, they're like rejected.
They reject every... I chose like the worst idea.
Because they actually rejected every bad idea.
Every amazing idea I had.
What do we do about the mechanical arms attacking from the elevator?
I'm gonna give me a ceiling.
Uh, high five.
The end of those arms are closed!
I'm not touching him!
My high fives aren't giving away willy nilly.
They are to be cherished.
I don't think my hands would survive a high five from them unless we think this.
See?
It's such a great idea!
They never like my good ideas!
Why ask for my opinion?
I should be able to disengage them.
I'll just need some time.
That leads us nicely to our next question.
Oh no.
Tails is taking a while and the arms are tightening their grip.
Oh my god!
Am I getting choked?
Why am I the one getting choked?
What the fuck?
Everyone else is okay?
Um...
Uh...
Cry.
Tails managed to do it!
Darlings, I'm happy to say this plan is perfect.
If everyone is ready, it's time to execute.
I'm ready.
Let's begin.
Alright, let's see what's up that elevator!
Alright, let's do it.
Did I do it?
I did it!
Yeah!
I knew the plan would go without a hitch.
So fucking easy.
We couldn't have made it this far without you both.
You have my gratitude.
Our planning beforehand was very thorough.
I must admit and it was executed to perfection.
Enough chatter.
Now we claim our real prize.
I have the safe code right here on these blueprints.
Let's claim our Faberge Chao egg.
Alright.
So this one?
No question.
This has got to be a safe with our treasure.
Entering the code on the blueprints.
Oh wait.
Entering the code on the blueprints and find out Rouge.
Oh, and it's Sweetheart.
Let's see.
23.3.
04.01.
Yeah!
What if it hatches?
It's here.
Haha!
I have it!
It's so ugly!
Alright, before anyone else is seen, let's get it out of here.
Hold on kiddo.
You can't be so hasty.
You truly think that's all there is to this egg?
The egg is real!
I know if the printer sees this, it's a secret.
Rouge, spit it out.
What are you hiding?
Only three of these eggs were ever made.
Each hiding their own individual secret.
I like secrets.
No one knows the secret.
Because anyone who's opened one of these has never lived to tell the tale.
Doki!
Doki Mato FPSV Tube.
Open it.
You can open the egg?
Yes.
It's a fucking egg.
Do you not see the gold thing right here?
Oh my god, Tess.
You're like a genius but yet you're so fucking stupid sometimes.
Yeah, sure I can.
And all of you will bear witness to its secret.
Rouge, I don't know if you should.
All you need to do is twist it.
Tick, tick, tick, tick.
Oh maybe that's why no one fucking... no one fucking lived because they died.
Is this a bomb?
Huh?
Why do we have a bomb on a fucking train?
Wait, I thought like the robot arms made sure we don't have bombs in this train.
Uh oh.
Rouge, has no one lived to tell the egg's secret?
Because each egg is a bomb?
Huh?
I think you're onto something, kid.
It sure sounds like a bomb.
We need to dispose... we need to dispose of that egg now.
Wait, if we throw it in the safe, it'll be fine.
It's like bomb proof.
Dispose of it?
After our hard work?
Rouge.
Fine, fine.
But what do we do?
Where do I put this thing?
Guys!
Enough talking!
Just fucking throw the bomb!
Why are we still talking?
That's an excellent question.
What do we do with it?
Whoa!
Oh my god, there's a lot of...
Tell the egg to stop.
Stop.
That's it.
Nothing.
I can't believe I just did that.
Okay, take one for the team.
Let's do it.
I'm gonna do it.
Give it to me!
I'm gonna be a hero!
Get away from this far spot.
Just remember me as I am a hero!
No!
Doki, Mato, FPSV2, we won't let you do it!
I mean, that's what they want.
Who are we to stop the microwave kids?
Obviously not going to sacrifice themselves.
Their body's far too scrawny to contain... Oh!
Just because I'm a tomato doesn't mean I won't be able to shield us from the fucking blast.
True.
Let's think of something else quickly.
Okay, clearly it doesn't work.
Okay.
Have Blaze stomp on the egg.
Throw it.
Lock it in the safe.
Quick!
Put the egg back, Rouge!
It's fine!
It's going back in!
Huh?
The safe won't lock.
The door's staying open.
Close the door and twist the dial!
I obviously am!
There must be some weird way to re-lock the door!
Please!
There's no other buttons or dials!
How are we supposed to...
Don't have time to mess with this.
Think of something else.
Oh my god!
It wasn't that!
That seemed like the...
Oh, this is a mistake.
Let's fuck it.
If we die, we die.
Are you insane?
Do you want us to... If we die, we die!
We need to dis...
We need to dispose of the bomb.
Dokimedo FPS VTube.
That is our goal.
Listen, I get that.
But!
Hear me out!
What if the egg isn't a bomb?
Wait.
That's right!
Dokimedo FPS VTube!
I think you're on to something!
Oh my god, I was cooking!
What's right?
Spit it out kiddo!
We don't have any time!
Okay, we clearly had a lot of time.
There was a lot of options.
Like, we had so much fucking time.
Sorry.
It's just...
SPL did say something interesting when we quizzed them about the train's manual.
Wait, we did?
What did he say?
Um, what's efficient and extremely accurate technology and solid to assist in keeping the train spotless?
Robotic...
Wait!
Are you telling me?
It was an illusion of choice?
Whatever page I asked for?
They can perform a variety of tasks.
Yeah, I said that!
I remember!
I was like, when the robotic arms know about the fucking bomb, it can't be a bomb!
I knew it!
I called it!
I was so smart.
I told you I remember things.
Those robotic arms.
In fact, I touched this in the elevator.
Seems to have a lot of functions here on the train.
I remembered.
If a bomb was brought onto a train, the skies would be as bright as a strawberry egg.
The arms should have detected it.
And would have allowed it on.
The only other person who knows the coming and going of the train is a conductor.
And he surely wouldn't allow such a thing either.
Wait, that's me.
So we're out of options.
Sorry I impersonated you a little bit, Tails.
I think we should wait.
And see what happens.
Okay, we wait.
I like the voice plays the most, I think.
Okay.
Oh!
The egg!
It opened!
It's hollow!
It's not a bomb at all!
You both really were onto something!
Phew!
My, my.
That's one way to get the heart racing.
I'm completely relieved.
Oh, sorry.
That had a little bit too much emotion.
I'm completely relieved.
Sorry.
I had a little intonation in there.
My hunch was right.
Thankfully.
Ah, what's inside?
Oh, bling bling!
Bedazzled chow!
Look at that sparkle and it's so heavy too!
Bling bling!
Bling bong bong bling bong bong bong bling bong bong bong The final secret to the Faberg chow egg is a chow covered in gems!
That's a bedazzled chow!
It's perfect It's exquisite It's revolutionary!
And it's worth a lot of money!
Is she drooling over a sparkly ornament?
I must admit it is stunning.
Said no one lived to tell the Faberg chow egg secret.
I wonder why if the egg wasn't a bomb.
Because they weren't as tough as us!
I don't know.
Who cares?
What a precious treasure!
A beauty to behold!
Maybe he didn't actually die of old age and just kept the secret with them?
No!
People keeping secrets?
As much fun as this has been, we should get out of here before we spot it.
Good call.
Let's go.
Is that it?
Do I not even have to interrogate them?
I mean, that's all they've been doing to be fair.
No one seems to suspect anything.
And the security guard is back at their post.
Hope they subdued the drink coaster food okay.
Thank you both for your assistance.
That hunt was exactly the thrill I was seeking.
What about the murder?
Do we just not care about the murder anymore?
Like, uh...
Sealing was strangely fun.
But I prefer to never do it again.
Fucking pussy.
Now, rouge.
Rouge?
Oh my god, what did she see?
She's completely absorbed in that bedazzle.
Oh, she's still looking at the bedazzle chow.
What is it, darling?
How about those blueprints?
Now that you're done with them, maybe we could take a look?
Well, I appreciate your assistance.
It's as I said, finders keepers.
I'll need them a little longer in case I missed any of them.
I don't have any other treasures.
But I promise to let you take a peek later.
I don't want to sound ungrateful, but I'm sure you get it, sweetheart.
I hope she's talking to me and not the child.
You can't just add sweetheart to the end of a sentence to make things better.
But I don't think there's any reason of her.
She's more powerful than me.
I'm not sure.
Well, we'll get out of your way for now then.
We have a murder mystery to attend to.
You know, the one for Amy's birthday, guys?
You know.
Before you go, Shadow gave me and Rouge one of these.
We passed through earlier.
A key!
Let me unlock the door so we can continue forward.
You know, we've had a lot of people mention you, Rouge.
But we also have just as much suspicion about Shadow.
He's unpredictable.
That one.
Good luck to you.
The door is unlocked.
Both of you, stay safe.
Thanks again.
I like how we're not even interrogating them.
We're just like, yep, they didn't do it.
The mystery continues.
They're just like, yep, alright.
Am I gonna get one guy?
Tails, we must search the trash bin.
It's empty.
Did I hear it all?
I've always believed in the thorough investigation.
Even peeking in the trash.
See, it's about persistence, Tails.
My dad told me that when he met my mother, he would drive her to work two hours away every Tuesday with flowers from his garden.
She quickly agreed to the date.
Bro, that's fucking...
Bro, that's weird.
And when she arrived at the restaurant, she found two dozen roses waiting for her.
Within a year, the two were married.
It's about caring, dedication, and persistence.
Yes!
Whether those was until she says yes.
It's romance!
That's very sweet.
But all that's in the bin is a lollipop stick.
A lollipop stick.
A lollipop stick?
Yeah, like the leftover stick from a lollipop.
That's all there is.
Can't believe I got one guy again.
Doki made a FPSV tube.
Is everything okay?
Do you need me to bring you a flower?
It's a clue!
Tails!
You don't know that!
It's a clue!
Ooh, jackpot.
Oh, nice pinball!
Cheating, cheating, cheating.
Do you think I can cheat?
Visit Twinkle Park.
I like how we don't talk about Balan's Wonderland.
Wonderworld?
Ready to get going?
Yeah, I am.
Let's find Shadow.
We're almost at the end of this murder mystery.
I can gamble?
Wait, I can gamble?
Nooooo!
You can play games!
The Slots!
Take me back!
Oh, no.
No!
We can't gamble.
In front of the child.
We couldn't gamble in front of the child.
Now's a good time to clean any of my pockets.
I knew you won't talk.
I knew exactly why you've been locking those doors.
It's hard to get a word in as you talk over me, man.
I have my reasons.
I...
No reason is convincing enough.
It's inconceivable what you did.
Hey, hey, hey!
What's going on?
Hey, guys!
Hey!
I see you made it here, Tails.
But I didn't expect the Iron Chef as well.
We'll see what you say when you microwave chili dogs delicious!
I'd like to know why you've been locking doors...
throughout the train shadow.
Well...
It seems Amy already knows.
So ask her.
Hmmm...
I'm not saying a thing.
You know, I will have to tell me why.
Now, if you could leave me be...
I have an appointment coming up.
With what?
You're just a locksmith.
You don't have any other job.
Be immersive.
Appointment?
Yeah, who wants to meet him here?
Well, Doki made a FPSV tube.
It seems like Shadow isn't going to talk.
Let's do some investigating.
He won't talk until his lawyer's here.
Alright, ready to find some answers, Tails?
Indubitably, my dear Doki made a FPSV tube.
Alright.
What will make him talk?
Oh!
Maybe he has a date!
Wait, why is there a computer?
Tails...
No...
Tails, I think we should check the trash.
Every trash bin has been empty, Doki made a FPSV tube.
And you've been disappointed every time...
No!
It'll be Doki's fault!
This time, it's different!
This time!
That one guy can't be right for once!
There's no way!
That one guy can't be right for once in his life!
Are you going to get sad again?
There's nothing in the trash bin.
Doki made a FPSV tube.
Hmm...
There's always something in the trash bin.
Alright, let's check the trash bin.
This time.
This is it.
This is the one guy.
What's this?
Ha!
It's...
Someone printed out the front page of a ticket website.
It's for the band...
Hot Honey?
Interesting.
Hot Honey is one of Amy's favorite bands.
Oh my god!
Shadow didn't get her a birthday present!
Let's add it to our inventory.
Shadow!
Are you sure this is just...
trash?
That is...
Shadow, I can't believe it.
I can't believe it, Shadow.
You got it last minute.
There's always success if you check the trash bin.
Crumpled paper is added to your inventory.
I can't believe it, Shadow!
You didn't fucking...
You didn't fucking get her a birthday present until you're on the train?
Better late than never.
They don't...
They told us about this interview.
I don't know.
The lounge has a computer complete with internet access for casual browsing.
How lovely.
Seems convenient.
It is a shame to be on the computer and missing those gorgeous views though.
I feel like if you're...
It's 8pm.
It's dark.
You must really need to use it.
Yes, I...
My life is now as a tomato playing Sonic the Hedgehog.
Oh, I thought that was it.
Okay.
Wait, maybe the keys?
Hmm.
The keys!
A keyring?
Must be Shadow's... the locksmith.
It's interesting.
There's only two keys.
I figured a locksmith...
would have a bunch.
Wait, didn't he give away all my keys though?
Wanna take it?
Rough times.
Thank you for the super chat.
Does that mean Amy is Latina?
Hahaha.
Keyring is added to your inventory.
Alright, what else?
I'm gonna check the door.
Oh, okay.
I thought like...
I thought like it would say something.
Can you open the wardrobe please?
Sure.
Wait, is there a reason for me to do it?
What if something falls out?
Or worse, someone leaps out?
Or worse, it's a jump scare!
I just think you should do it.
Alright, open the wardrobe.
Wait, tails.
Yeah.
Do it.
Be a man.
Be a fox man.
Alright.
Tough love.
I'll get it.
Today you'll become a fox man, Tails.
Here goes nothing!
Ah!
Oh, just some sweaters.
See?
Not bad, huh?
Just dusty.
Haha.
Boo!
Ah!
Hahaha.
Sorry, couldn't help it.
Doki made a FPS VTuber.
I'm fragile.
Okay.
Clearly it wasn't... Oh wait, what's this?
Tails, do you see this?
What is that?
A pull string?
Doki made a FPS VTube.
It's gotta activate something.
Whoa!
There's a secret passage!
There's a full... Okay, she didn't say that.
There's a full passageway back there!
Come on, we have to see where this leads.
He's curious.
This must mean something big.
Wait!
The library!
There's a secret passageway from the...
This changes everything!
Secret tunnel!
I don't believe it.
Wait, how the fuck does that work?
Wait, wait, wait a minute.
Oh, there's a... Wait, wait a minute.
Wait.
How does...
Wait...
If the train is moving...
How does that work?
Wait, I'm a little confused now.
Yeah, but the train is moving.
So, like, how did the...
Alright.
Through the passageway before they spot us.
I'm confused.
My brain hurts now.
How the fuck...
Wait...
We need to add that to our inventory.
Hidden passageway.
Wait, I think I got the clues.
Yeah!
It's time to interrogate Shadow.
Ultimate life form.
It's time!
There's nothing I can do to help you.
Let me be.
That stair.
So cold.
Burr.
We will get you... We will get out of here, actually.
Don't keep me at our FPS, B-Tube!
We certainly will not!
Alright.
Can I take your order?
I'll take you up on that coffee.
When I'm back in the dining car, I'll whip that right up.
Coffee on the train.
There's no better combination.
Mmm...
Some marshmallows will make it perfect.
Sure.
Cause that's...
edgy.
Alright, let's actually interrogate him.
He likes it black.
Like his soul.
Shadow, we have questions for you.
Will you three get out?
I'm busy.
As I said, I have an appointment at 10.
10-2.
Sorry, but this is important.
Shadow, we've questioned everyone on this train.
And every single person I've mentioned running into you.
You've been locking every door in this train.
And... and I know why.
Ah!
Pray tell why.
I was locking all the doors.
Time to reveal my hot tip!
Hope everyone is ready for a scoop found by yours truly.
We're ready.
According to the map, the next car is the conductor's car.
Where Sonic was stationed.
This door right here in the lounge car is the only car that leads to the conductor's car.
Following...
So, Shadow was locking all the doors for one reason and one reason alone.
To keep Sonic from escaping the conductor car.
So you think Shadow was trapping Sonic?
I sure do!
He locked the conductor's car, then locked all the others.
So one locked door wasn't suspicious.
I don't know guys.
I think Amy's wrong.
Because it's never the first thing.
Here, conjecture.
You all get out and leave me be.
Well, my source can back up the...
Who's my source?
Me?
Source, trust me.
They remain anonymous, but I think that...
My source claims they never saw Sonic again after he went into the conductor's car.
Why?
Trust me bro.
Because he was trapped and couldn't leave the conductor's car.
Reckless speculation.
This is how you do your detective work.
Journalist.
Is the logic sound though?
Was Shadow trapping...
Source, it's my birthday.
I'm right, it's my birthday.
Happy birthday.
I'll play along and follow this train of logic, Amy.
I shall then lock the door to the conductor's car.
Imprisoning Sonic.
Then how is Sonic found in the dining car?
I think the ma- I'm sorry.
TokimatoFPSVtube and I can explain the car change, however.
TokimatoFPSVtube, what evidence do we have that shows Sonic could have gotten into the dining car?
Well, obviously it's this.
Like, what else?
Or let's do we- Oh yeah, it's this.
Just get my thoughts in order.
Think!
Okay, I got it right.
It's think time.
Don't worry.
Just gonna play a little video game, guys.
Sorry, my mom said I can't pause this game.
It's okay.
Boop!
Oh, there's like no more like- Uh, oh nevermind.
Oh wait, this is easier!
This is like easier than the fucking...
Uh, than the straight line thing.
Why would this one be easier?
This is like literally endgame, isn't it?
Yay!
Guys, it's easier, I swear.
What?
A secret passage?
Yes, it's literally right in front of us, Amy.
So someone could have used the passage, snuck through the library car, walked past the distracted boys playing arcade, and safely arrived at the dining car to eat all those chained dogs and then get a food coma?
Excellent work, DokiMatoFPSVTube.
Hmm...
That just my theory- Yeah, just a little bit, by the way.
The shadow murdered Sonic in the conductor car, but then thought the crime scene being so close to the station was suspicious?
Shadow picked up Sonic, locked the door to the conductor car on the way out, and dropped the body off at the dining car?
Happy birthday, it's my birthday!
Are you officially accusing Shadow of murder?
I am!
But of course, this is just a theory.
A game theory.
I don't have any evidence to back this up other than my hot scoop.
Seems Tails and I were more thrilled than you.
Huh?
The shadow's not gonna talk.
Then I'll humor you once again!
The shadow traveled through the hidden passage and appeared in the library car?
Then how did S.B.M.
Vesper not see him?
Umm... well...
I suppose it would be hard to sneak around two people.
DokiMatoFPSVTuber, do you have any guesses?
Wait, what?
Okay.
Because...
Oh, S.B.O.
was reading!
Wait, it's both right.
Like, S.B.O.
was reading and...
Oh, wait, Vector was with Knuckles.
Yeah, I mean...
They were...
Well, Vector was with Knuckles.
That's true.
Vector was with Knuckles and would have seen Shadow enter the library car.
See?
Things are falling into place.
But what about S.B.O.?
I believe S.B.O.
Yeah, it's an illusion of choice!
It was both right!
S.B.O.
reading in the library checks out.
That's what he told me too.
He's lying.
What?
What was that, Shadow?
When I completely obliterated Knuckles and Vector at that whatever game, I left the saloon car.
What?
I spent so much time looking for S.B.O.
but he was not there.
He was not in the...
It was the poet?
Like, I'd believe you.
You're currently my number one suspect.
What?
It wasn't the butler?
Why were you even searching for S.B.O.?
Huh?
Bum Bum!
You must know I needed to give him a key.
As if.
Why would a locksmith be giving away his keys?
Shadow has been giving away a lot of keys, actually.
Everyone but us seems to have one.
That's true.
Everyone's been able to unlock the next door for us.
I didn't know that!
Shadow's been passing out keys?
How cool!
I can't believe he's doing his job!
Perhaps Doki made our FPSV2, but now I can further validate Shadow's claims.
Oh, it's a keyring.
It's also like the last thing.
We can do what?
Doki made our FPSV2.
What evidence supports Shadow's claim that he was... Oh wait, no.
Yeah.
He doesn't have a lot of keys left.
He just has two.
He is the key man.
What else would we be doing with all these keys?
That feels good.
Now to get my thoughts in order.
I think... Oh shit.
Okay.
Alright.
Game break.
Time to play my video games.
This is also gonna be... Okay.
It's gonna be like the blast.
I think the blast is actually easier than the the little...
the fire strike.
Sorry, I got distracted.
No!
No, don't...
Oh no!
This is actually the worst I've ever done!
No!
Oh okay.
I made it.
I barely made it.
Okay.
I still got it.
There's only one reason.
I have exactly two keys on that key.
Those were two keys Shadow meant to give Espeon Vector.
No way!
Whoa!
One of his own key.
Can one of those be for him?
I have my own key on me.
Interesting.
Likely story.
It's my birthday.
So let's say Shadow's telling the truth.
Then what?
Huh?
If Shadow didn't murder Sonic and bring him to the dining car, then what possible reason could he have for locking all the doors?
Hmm...
She's right.
Her theory is strong.
Tails and I certainly haven't presented any possibilities.
If Shadow really insisted on Sonic's murder, it's cause he didn't buy you a birthday gift.
He's a leech!
I think Doki made a FPSB2 and I know exactly why Shadow was locking all that doors.
Why does he keep including me too?
I'm just a butler.
Slash microwave guy.
Huh?
Has everyone today given you a birthday present?
Yeah!
Yeah Amy!
Almost everyone.
Yeah.
Everyone's been so sweet.
Everyone...
He's just forgetful, Doki.
Hop off my goat!
He's...
How dare you say that about my Oshiii!
Shadow and Sonic haven't given me anything yet, but that's okay.
Just them being here is an... Oh my god, Amy, you're too nice.
Understood.
Thank you, Amy.
Doki made a FPSB2?
Uh, yes, Tails?
I have a theory.
Find a piece of evidence to support it.
We know Shadow walked through every train door, locking the exit.
And he gave everyone stationed in the car a key.
Except for you, me, and Amy.
That's right!
The conductor gave her Amy her birthday key, not Shadow!
So why would he lock all the doors and not give us a key?
He wanted to keep us away!
Was Shadow locking all the doors to keep us away?
Bum bum bum!
Not us, Doki made a FPSB2.
I'm making a leap here, but stick with me.
I think Shadow was trying to keep Amy away!
Oh my god, finally!
We knew this for like 20 minutes ago!
Holy shit!
Guys, any time now to solve that mystery about Sonic's death!
Like...
Hmm... Excuse me?
Shadow will never do that!
It's my birthday!
You know it's my birthday, right?
Don't you, Shadow?
Hmm...
How dare Doki made a FPSB2!
Show me evidence!
Huh?
Is Shadow trying to keep me away?
Prove it!
You've been so thorough or whatever!
What proof do you have?
Uh, okay!
Tell us if Shadow was trying to keep just Amy away?
Why?
What if it shows what Shadow didn't want Amy to know?
That he fucking bought this her birthday gift last minute on the fucking train!
That feels right.
Alright, gaming time!
I hope this is the last one!
Hahaha!
Woooo!
Guys, all I'm saying is I have never lost a single one.
It doesn't matter if like I was like one ring away from losing.
I still haven't lost though.
That doesn't mean I lost.
Chat.
It just meant I did it.
There you go.
Woo!
This has to be endgame.
Look at all the fucking blasts!
What?
Reading through the trash?
What the fuck is wrong with you?
What is that?
We found this in the trash bin next to the printer!
Hot Honey!
It's a banned ticket website.
Tails, don't!
This is Hot Honey's website!
No way!
Hot Honey!
Oh no, they used Ticketmaster.
No!
Shadow, you're gonna get scammed with all the fees!
Shadow!
Shadow, no!
Don't fucking fall for Ticketmaster!
It's the band I'm currently obsessed with.
Jereme B is my current favorite.
All the members have B after their name.
Isn't it cute?
I haven't gone to any other shows yet to see them though.
Their tickets are really hard to get.
You have to be really online at a specific time.
And they sell out- they don't need a sponsorship.
They're literally having Monopoly on fucking concert tickets.
Like, what do you mean?
Like...
They don't- they don't need it because they're literally the only place you can grab tickets unless you wanna buy scalpers.
But even then, they're still fucking fees!
Okay, anyway.
They sell out every minute.
So the question becomes, why was this paper found in the train car Shadow was stationed in?
Watch yourself, Fox.
The situation is becoming much clearer.
I don't know how Tails figured things out so soon.
But I see where he's heading.
Bro, he's just playing the video game faster than me.
The printout of the hot Honey Band tickets website exists because...
I don't know, fucking he was trying to buy tickets?
Like, what- where else would this go to?
Shadow's also a big hot- okay, yeah, that's another choice.
Well, oi!
Shadow, is this true?
Are you trying to get more concert tickets for my birthday?
Hmm...
I done a poor job hiding the surprise, it seems.
Well, did you get it?
Yes, I'm trying to get you concert tickets for your birthday.
Hmm...
Shadow!
She didn't even do it!
Like...
Like, he didn't even do it though!
He couldn't!
I used that printer earlier and I found it difficult to manage.
When logging onto the website, did you print the homepage by accident?
Uh, Jesus, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yes, that's exactly what happened.
I'm not fantastic with computers, admittedly.
Wait, the ultimate life form is not a gamer?
What?
He doesn't represent the people?
But...
I thought... I thought you were supposed to be the gamer edgelord.
Nooooo!
I can't believe this.
After I accused you of murder!
Spill everything, Shadow!
The cat's out of the bag!
I wanna know everything!
He didn't get the tickets in me.
Like, fine.
The surprise is ruined anyway.
Probably our fault there.
Sorry, that's all the detective's job, I suppose.
When I arrived on the train, I realized everyone else had a gift except for me.
Worried for my social status, I immediately began brainstorming my ideas and saw the computer.
I remember Amy had never seen Hot Honey live and looked it up.
That's when I accidentally printed the homepage.
The concert tickets weren't actually on sale, I realized, but would be available soon.
Is that the appointment you keep speaking of?
The time you're able to actually buy the concert tickets?
Precisely.
I haven't purchased... Yeah, I know!
I told you!
Bro!
Okay, I literally, if they let me talk, I would have fucking... this murder party would be done in an hour.
And you had to keep Amy away while I waited to buy the tickets.
So I began locking all the doors.
But for the safety of everyone, I handed out keys so they could get in and out.
Telled them not to let anyone through.
He's worried of his social status.
Like, look, it took him a lot of years to craft this social status.
It didn't work.
Amy still managed to make it here somehow.
It's because the conductor gave me this.
Yeah!
This key opens up any door on the train.
I've gone through every locked door with ease.
The plans fade of law.
Journalist mode.
I should have guessed.
It's a well-known privilege.
Shadow, hi.
Your gesture is so sweet.
And after I accused you too.
How about this?
Let's buy the tickets later and to make it up to you, you can come with...
Wait, bro, it's... what?
Why would she make it up for her?
Like for Shadow?
It's her birthday.
She's the one that didn't even get the birthday present.
What?
I don't understand.
Like, why?
He's the one that fucked up.
I don't know if...
Too late.
It's happening.
I can't wait.
A show of a lifetime.
Fine.
It's like she's paying for her own fucking tickets.
Happy birthday, Amy.
Thanks for buying my tickets.
I expect lots of pictures from the concert, you two.
Seems that Mr. Shadow's locked door has finally reached the end.
I blame my source for all of this.
That wasn't a hot tip at all.
They need me to believe Shadow was behind everything?
My credibility as a journalist reported down the drain.
I'm curious.
Who is this source of your big scoop?
I'd like to know as well.
Sorry.
Strictly confidential.
Trust me, bro.
My credibility may be shot, but my principle must stay intact.
I have a strong feeling I know who exactly is your source.
Is it Sonic?
Huh?
But we need to investigate one last area.
The conductor's car.
Oh, is it the conductor?
I'll come with you.
I'd love to know who's been dragging my name throughout the mud.
I'll join you as well.
I'll see you through the end.
We're more than happy to have you both.
Doki made our FPSV tube.
I had to say it, but I believe our investigation finally is coming to a close.
Oh my god, we're gonna figure it out!
It's being clear.
Has it really?
I honestly think Sonic's in a coma.
Not like actual coma, but in a food coma from all the chili dogs.
We'll pin down Sonic's murder for good!
Right on then.
Let's do it!
Alright, nice.
Anything else?
Okay.
Let's finish this.
It's now or never!
The conductor's car.
Truly surround my evidence before I continue.
In my short time working on this train, I haven't visited a conductor's car yet.
Feels...
empty?
Yeah, where's the conductor?
Wait, where's- Yeah!
Where's the conductor?
That's odd.
I haven't seen him throughout the train at all.
As fast as we saw him, we saw him when he left the dining car.
Something clearly happened here.
Nothing we can't figure out, teehee!
Come on!
Time to investigate!
Whoa.
Obviously, the spilled cup.
Did this fall over when the train sped up?
Did he have a heart attack?!
Not sure.
Wait, what's it say on the mug?
A cup of joe in your hand, wife by your side, paradise.
Alright, alright.
We get it.
He loves his wife.
Which wife?
Okay.
Not that.
Oh, the arms!
When the arms broken!
Wait, what's this?
What's this?
Was someone playing darts?
That's not a throwing dart.
That's a blow- Wait!
It wasn't a food coma?!
That's a blow dart.
Someone brought this weapon onto the train.
That shouldn't be possible.
How did he bring the- How did he bring it?
How did he bring it?
Tails is right.
Tails, the train detects any weapons on a passenger train before letting them abroad.
Let's make note of this.
Blow darts add in your inventory.
Okay, there's no way there's anything else in the trash.
I don't need- Yeah, see?
You're satisfied with finding clues here before, huh?
I know they say always check the trash bin, but I'm good.
I'll go on a high note.
See, I told you there's nothing in that trash bin!
This robot has been completely torn off.
Ugh, how creepy.
That arm is powerful.
It'd be tough to break out its grip.
A lot of people here have strength to tear this off.
But the question is why?
A confrontation definitely occurred in this room!
We should log this!
Aye aye, sir.
Broken robot arm.
Yeah, I think we have enough clues.
Okay.
Amy!
I have the clues ready!
I'm ready to- Oh, hey.
Oh.
I'm gonna skip.
Oh, next being for nasal medication was the- What?
Oh, the next ad.
I shouldn't have skipped that.
Okay, I was like, huh?
Perhaps too much detail.
Oh my god, there's him!
Look at him!
He looks so young!
Look at this doggo.
Alright, Amy.
I'm ready to solve the case!
It's been- You know this game is supposed to be two hours max?
Yeah.
Think you have enough evidence for me to call everyone here?
What do you think?
Jokey made of FPSV tube.
Ready to solve this case?
Yes!
Hello everyone!
This is the birthday girl speaking!
Please report to the conductor car.
At once!
This is it!
Hello everybody.
Sonic's not here cause he's fucking dead.
Wonderful to have you all here.
Tails and I are ready to announce our primes!
I am?
Okay.
Oh, I'm- I don't need to do it.
Oh, okay.
I do.
With assistance from Jokey made of FPSV tube!
Why hasn't Sonic showed up?
Huh?
Sonic?
Vector!
Real quick, can you come with me to get Sonic?
He must still be pretending to be dead, lazy bum.
Ready, let's go get him!
Alright, let's get him to wrap Sonic.
Let me tell you darlings, this has been a delight.
A delight?
The air in here is so intense.
I love it.
I-I don't know.
My voice for Rouge keep- fucking changing.
Nothing like the thrill of mystery.
The train has so many amenities.
I feel so catered to.
Admittedly, I've been having a lot of fun myself.
The amusement of a chase.
I see why you're a detective outside of this mystery SPL.
Wait, he's a detective?
I thought he was a ninja.
Yeah, and I love a good thrill it seems.
I thought he was a ninja!
But on this train, I am but a humble po- Is he a ninja detective?
I'd be willing to be- do an event like this again.
It says here the train does escape rooms as well.
He's a detective ninja?
Bro, he can do anything!
Fucking nerd.
I love escape- I fucking hate escape.
Count me in!
I'm so glad everyone's having a good time.
Maybe we could get rid of a train just to relax- Oh wait, maybe we could- sorry, I was like get rid of a train.
Maybe we can ride a train just to relax some time.
Yeah, that'd be fun too.
AHHHHHHHHH!
Whoa!
Huh?
What in the world?
Oh, okay, wait, that's- What in the world?
That's Amy's voice!
Quick!
Oh wait, quick, where's Amy?
Oh my god!
He's dead!
He's not responding to us!
Sonic!
SONIC!
Is he hurt?
Guys, trust me, I checked his pulse, he's definitely dead.
Um...
Is he hurt?
Why isn't he moving?
Sonic, Sonic, can you hear us?
He's banged up.
If there's a pulse, it's weak.
Oh my god, he actually has a pulse?
No fucking way!
Set him down.
Make sure his head is propped up.
I'll help you.
Hmm...
I knew one of you would take this too far.
Which one of you did this to Sonic?
On my birthday, no less!
Yes!
Could this have been one of us?
Sorry, I'm like, yee-haw.
Y'all, could this have been one of us?
There's no one else here, Knuckles!
So I'll ask again.
Which one of you did this?
Is this a conductor?
Eggman!
Surprise, Eggman!
I can't believe it.
It was not a food coma.
This is...
inexcusable.
Sonic's hurt.
I'm going to expose the monster who did this.
Tails is not having it.
I thought Sonic could handle anything, but...
somehow he met his match.
Who murdered...
Who murdered Sonic?
I'm going to help you get the bottom of this...
I'm going to help you get the bottom of this, Tails.
Absolutely!
Me too, y'all.
Same.
We're going to figure out something.
We're going to figure out exactly what happened in this room.
And punish the one responsible.
San Diego, thank you for the Akasuba!
Thank you, thank you!
Don't kill her.
I'm not the killer.
Sonic!
I'm writing my wrong.
I must take down the murderer.
Tails.
No key made out FPSV tube.
I have a big question to ask.
Who in this room did this?
Who killed Sonic the Hedgehog?
Wait.
What?
Amy!
That can't be right.
I can be the murderer.
That's right.
Wait.
It's actually not Amy?
Oh my God.
Maybe it's, It's the ninja detective.
Wait, it's the ninja detective because he was gone!
You're accusing Espio?
You have nothing!
Vector's been active.
We discovered a hidden passage!
Espio could lock the library at any time because Tails and I find a hidden passage!
Bum bum bum!
Speedrun to the lounge car!
In the lounge, the hidden passage exits behind the wardrobe.
I feel lucky we even found it.
Not only would Espio avoid any locked doors...
Vector is his boyfriend.
But that would put him in the car.
But just before this one...
You have no evidence I used any secret passage.
I answered...
Oh, the blue dirt because he's a ninja!
I was reading the entire time.
Remember, it's true.
You didn't miss a question.
I think Doki made an FPS VTuber and I can explain that too.
Doki made an FPS VTube.
How did Espio know everything in the train manual he was reading?
Bro, I don't know.
Hahaha!
A ninja like him!
Speedrun!
Speedreads!
I don't know anything about lit ninjas, but I assume that's true.
He's fluent in 17 different languages.
And bro, what the fuck?
How much perfect can you be?
Not perfect enough because you got caught, bitch.
By a tomato.
What are you getting at?
You picked a random book from the shelf and met...
What the fuck is wrong with you, Espio?
That's way too much work.
Just normal ninjas.
Just normal ninja stuff.
Just to guarantee yourself a clean alibi.
What?
That's absurd.
Memorizing a whole book?
I know this is a talented bunch, but that seems like a lie.
I don't know.
It is seen as plausible.
Espio is particularly skilled.
He's a genius.
Howdy y'all.
I've known Espio for a long time.
He once speedread a book I was reading just to spoil the ending for me.
Oh my gosh.
That's messed up, man.
If I'm right.
And Espio quickly memorized...
Bro, he just hates him because he doesn't like that there's somebody smarter than him.
Before entering the hidden passage.
Espio is a kid that your mom compares you to.
Bob, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Then Espio could have met Sonic in the conductor's car where he was murdered.
Wait, but why was he in the dining car then?
Since we're only talking what is, let me throw something at you.
How was I to know about the hidden passage?
It's hidden.
That's right.
Bro, stop defending him, bro.
The...
The chameleon bus he can't be sacked.
How many times do you have to even know if it was there?
You said it yourself, kid.
You were lucky to even find the passage.
Doki made a FPSB tube and I might not have the evidence to answer your question.
But we know someone who does.
Doki made a FPSB tube.
Who here has evidence to prove Espio knew about the hidden passage?
What?
Rouge, the bat!
Rouge, we need to see those blueprints.
Blueprints?
I didn't even get vaccinated for this.
You saw blueprints?
Whatever.
I already used it to scout for more treasures.
I just came up cold.
You can have it.
Blueprints are added to my inventory.
There we go.
This right here is a blueprint to the entire train.
Espio could have easily used this to find the hidden passage.
Because he got it first.
What makes you think I ever saw those blueprints?
Rouge had them.
Because you were in the library first!
Doki made a FPSB tube.
Do you have an answer for him?
How could Espio have seen those blueprints?
He found them before Rouge did.
Wait, what?
Yeah, he found them before Rouge did.
Rouge, where did you find the blueprints?
Oh, um, the library car.
He'll stuff with the brochures.
I checked the saloon car first.
Then found the blueprints after leaving.
So that means Espio had time to find the blueprints So that means Espio had time to find the blueprints and discover the hidden passageway!
In my theory, Espio looked at the blueprints and then used the hidden passage to get to Sonic.
Within Amy's guidelines, the murderer can kill a single participant however they choose.
The logistics are still vague, but Doki made an FPSB tube and I have evidence on how Sonic was murdered!
I'm unsure how much Espio caused Sonic, but Doki made an FPSB tube and I have evidence on how it was done!
Ha!
Oh, this is rich.
Pray tell.
If I murdered Sonic, how did I do it?
Ah, blow dart you fucking ninja!
Now to farm my argument.
Come on, focus.
Oh god, wait, this wasn't over?
Guys, it wasn't over.
I thought it was over, but there's two more rounds of this.
Guys, there was actually more.
It's okay, we got this.
What?
First death?
This is bullshit!
Oh my god, my actual first death!
That was actually bullshit.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe.
I can't believe that happened.
Like, why would I fucking be at the springs?
Oh my god.
I can't believe that happened.
I can't believe it.
My perfect...
My perfect world record.
My streak.
The blow dart was found here in the conductor room.
Oh!
I believe SPL uses this to knock Sonic unconscious.
Nice.
So you mean...
Sonic might just be knocked out?
Yes, he has a pulse!
Like, he's not fucking dead.
Like...
I'm not sure.
He's more banged up than what a blow dart would do.
According to Amy's rules, a blow dart counts as a kill for the murder mystery.
My theory, therefore, is plausible.
Plausible, you say?
Then why are there so many holes?
Like what, huh?
Like what?
Mr. Smartass.
You deny these allegations?
Of course I do.
Let me present the first fatal flaw.
If I knocked out Sonic in the conductor's car, then how was Sonic found in the dining car?
Shoot, that's a good point.
Tails was Vector!
Vector!
He's a muscle!
I locked all the cars and Espo didn't have a key.
He would have had to take the hidden passage back.
If he took the hidden passage back, he'd end up back in the library.
Though he made a FPSV2 and I know another way, it could have been done.
VECTOR!
What piece of evidence do we need to take a closer look?
Um, we only have this.
I only have this, so...
Like, I don't know.
Does this mean anything?
Like...
Oh, it's not?
The menu?
Oh, it's not the menu.
Wait, what?
Ahahaha!
Uhhhhhhhhh!
Hahahaha!
The map?
Oh, okay.
It was the process of elimination.
It was the map.
The blueprints.
Yeah, what is my argument?
We're getting THINK!
Dokimeta FPSV2!
What does the blueprint mean?
Hahahaha!
What?
What is the blueprint for?
I'm so confused.
What could a blueprint do?
It's just...
AHHHHH!
What?
I jumped!
I swear to god, I jumped!
Oh my god, think.
Think, Doki, think.
What did it mean?
What did the blueprint mean?
I actually don't know!
I'm so confused!
Oh!
Let me grab this real fast.
Okay, nice.
We made it.
We just have to not die.
Oh!
Nice.
There we go.
We just got it now.
Oh my god, how did the fucking level difficulty jump that much?
Alright, let's take a look.
What does this mean?
If Ezreal didn't take the secret passage to get to the guiding car, then what route did he get to Sonic there?
There's a path above the conductor car, and it goes all the way to the dining car?
Oh!
I didn't even see that area.
I didn't even see that too!
What the fuck?
How the fuck was I supposed to notice that?
Is this some sort of long attic?
According to these blueprints, he vented!
There's a hidden path in the ceiling that leads straight to the dining car.
I can't believe it!
He fucking vented!
Perhaps you can access it through the vent over there?
The vent, of course!
That must be the entrance to the path!
Allow me... Howdy y'all!
Allow me to check it!
Pretty lady!
My word!
There is a path back there, and a track, y'all!
A track?
How?
A track for the robot arms, I think, my lady.
Y'all.
I'm gonna have to move the arms to move throughout the train.
I just got this, but this game seems very forgiving.
The reason you're playing it!
Jesus, I'm so mad!
Thank you for the super chat!
So you're saying...
I somehow fit with Sonic in that bed and took him to the dining car.
Tails, you're a smart kid.
I know you realize we both couldn't fit up there.
Espio's right.
This is feeling flimsy, Tails.
I need an answer.
My name is getting dragged around here.
This is pathetic, Tails.
Just because I know more languages than you Just because I know more languages than you doesn't mean you have to be jealous.
How on earth would I get Sonic through that fence?
It has to be the arms at this rate.
Like, what else?
I can't do this.
You can do this!
Objection!
Oh, thank...
Wait, sorry, I can't object yet.
I'm still thinking.
Don't worry, we got this.
Wee-oo!
Wait, what?
How the fuck did I get hit?
What the fuck?
Okay, that scared me, actually.
Oh, there's too many things going on on my screen.
No!
Oh, there's way too many things going on on my screen right now.
Oh, no, please, I need...
Nooooooooo!
How the heck... Bro!
What?
Okay, okay.
We got this.
Bro, this is actually really...
This is the final countdown.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No!
Oh, this is bad, this is bad, this is...
AHHHH!
It's over, it's so over!
It's so over!
Nooooo!
It's over, there's no way.
I got knocked, like...
How am I not hitting any of these rings?
It's so over!
Oh, my God.
Bro, this is actually a lot difficult than before.
Like, they're like not even generous with the rings.
That's like the worst part.
Ohhhhh!
Okay.
Wait, wait, this is it, this is it, this is it.
No!
No, okay, 68!
Okay, just...
Don't fuck it up.
Don't fuck it up, Doki.
Yes!
Alright, nice.
Okay.
They were definitely not generous at all this time.
Everybody saw the broken robot arm on the ground, right?
Clearly a fight broke out here and one of those robot arms was a casualty!
But what if one of the broken arms actually caught Sonic?
Knuckles said there's a track the robot arms use that continues through the vent.
A robot arm could have grabbed Sonic, passed out from a blow dart, and carried him to the dining car.
Could that be true?
Could you really do it, Espio?
Take a look at Sonic.
He's clearly banged up.
Could the fight happen between Sonic and the robot arms?
I can see that!
Those arms do look powerful!
Sonic doesn't fall easily.
But if he's woozy from a blow dart, the arms could have gotten him.
Interesting theory, Tails.
But you have to admit, these are a lot of coincidences.
These are a lot of coincidences.
I might not be able to link everything directly to Espio yet, but I found one inconsistency.
I found one inconsistency.
What kind of inconsistency?
Someone here received false information!
I believe that information comes from Espio!
comes from Espio!
Who received that information?
Wait, what?
Okay...
Oh, Amy!
Wait, what?
Amy, you received a hot scoop, did you not?
I think it's time you tell us where that scoop came from.
Okay, I got a little confused with the way they worded that.
I was like, wait, I thought we already know it's Amy.
So I was like, I got it wrong!
The way they worded that was so confusing!
I was like...
Tails, you're right!
Espio lied to me!
Espio told me Shadow was locking doors to trap Sonic!
But we found out Shadow was trying to keep me from discovering my birthday surprise!
That scoop came from you, Espio?
How dare you!
Word, they're going to do the Phoenix Wright breakdown.
No, of course not, Amy!
Must have misheard me.
You know her, she's so ditzy.
Hehe!
Misheard you?
Are you calling me stupid on my birthday?
Yes, I said Sonic's going to get trapped with all these locked doors!
I was just looking out for my fellow passenger safety.
I didn't blame Shadow.
The ultimate life form.
I don't know, Espio.
What?
The evidence might not be airtight, but there's a lot being thrown at you that makes sense.
I have to agree.
You want us to believe you're lazily reading the whole time?
You, Detective Ninja, know 17 languages.
While you were stationed in a room with a hidden passage?
Gah!
And now you're lying to me?
On my birthday?
Of all days.
He better have a really good birthday present.
Gaslighting me.
Works for sure.
Look, Espio is clearly not very good at gaslighting.
And now you're lying?
I believe the murderer used the train's controls to move Sonic from the conductor's car to the dining car.
And lied to Amy, casting further blame on Shadow for no other reason.
I can't believe it!
Espio wouldn't let Amy win on her birthday.
That is so fucked up.
It's literally her birthday.
When examining everyone's... Wait, is Amy's birthday actually on April Fool's?
Like...
One clearly stands out as the weakest.
I believe it's clear to everyone that it can only have been one person.
It was... Oh my god!
Professor Lee!
It was you!
Espio!
This reminds me of a puzzle.
You were the one who murdered Sonic the Hedgehog!
They did the thing!
So...
Oh!
Oh...
Hey...
Guys...
Sonic, you're okay!
Sonic...
And just as we solved the mystery...
Espio was the murderer!
Right...
He's not okay!
Sonic?
Espio jumped me in the conductor car...
Bro, what the fuck is this?
Dang it!
You got me!
A blow dart though?
Really?
It's non-lethal poison.
You'll just be sleepy for a while.
Great, I could use a nap.
No, wait!
There's something important!
Espio let me there...
Bro, he's like not okay.
He's...
Someone get him to the hospital.
He is not okay.
Something important?
I need everyone to listen.
The trains...
What?
What's that?
Sonic, are you feeling alright?
Do you need to lie back down?
No.
We need to all...
Get off this train!
We're not safe!
What?
When I...
Oh!
It's Eggman's robot!
I knew that.
I was just testing you guys.
I was just testing you guys on Sonic lore.
Wait, is the conductor even...
Is the conductor even real?
You're so excited to tell me all about the features of the train?
But what he was telling me...
Was the conductor...
Was the conductor Eggman all along?
I had a bad feeling.
I had to see the power source.
The conductor hadn't even seen it.
When we took a look, we realized...
The train is powered by a Flicky!
A Flicky?
The tiny animal?
There's only one person twisted enough to use a Flicky as a power source.
Dr. Eggman!
I told the conductor the train needed to be destroyed.
He refused.
The way the conductor was describing it...
Is more than simple.
It's the conductor's friend.
The train is his co-conductor.
You're not serious.
Wait, where is the conductor?
They certainly didn't tell me in that interview.
Right as we saw the Flicky...
I felt a sting in my shoulder.
It was...
Where the fuck was the conductor?
Wouldn't Espio see the conductor?
Oh...
Espio left.
The lights in the room started to glow red.
Oh, evil...
Evil hands.
Oh no.
Not the evil hands.
Oh, there he is!
Oh, okay, there's the conductor.
What are you doing?
I knew something was wrong.
And stood up.
The arms came for me next.
I spin dashed through the robot arm.
Sliced it off the rail it was on.
I'm amazed I was able to do any of that.
Poisoned.
But another robot arm managed to grab me and pin me to the floor.
Wait, where did he go though?
The conductor screamed as the arms approached him.
But I was hit quite a bit before it got to me.
Wait, it's not over?
Well, we solved the mystery.
How much more?
I thought this was a simple murder mystery!
Oh no.
Everyone, I have something to admit.
Now for the real... Tutorials over.
Over!
Alright.
Yes, we know!
I murdered Sonic the Hedgehog.
Yeah, we already knew that man.
Guys, we did it!
We finished the tutorial!
This situation is getting so serious.
Why would you not tell us?
Just tell us.
I thought that's how the murder games work.
Darling...
You shoot someone with a blow dart, they die.
Are you crazy?
It's just a make believe game!
No one should get hit with my blow dart!
Okay, she should have put that in the rules.
She's literally in a room filled with people that have killed things.
And are very competitive.
She should literally clarify that in the TOS or something.
I was just following the rules.
Yeah, see?
Eggman corrupted the rules.
It's laced with a non-lethal...
Are we sure it's non-lethal?
What is that?
It says, use this blow dart on Sonic stationed in the conduct...
I'm surprised Eggman actually made it non-lethal.
You know?
Like, he could have easily got rid of him once and for all.
Thank you again for choosing the Mirage Express.
Staff!
What is this?
Instructions?
I was giving the blow dart along with that card.
It's signed, Staff.
Who gave this to you?
Come to think of it...
One of the robotic arms handed it to me.
Oh!
Weapons shooting out on a train?
What is the larger picture here?
Oh!
Who instructed... I wonder...
Who is the main villain in Sonic the Universe?
Amy.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, if Tails said that, I would have been like, Tails, what the fuck?
Who or what?
Tokimedo.
FPSVTube.
Who do you think attacked Sonic and handed Espio the blow dart?
The train itself.
The conductor.
The conductor was...
Secret Eggman!
Oh.
Okay.
Something wanted Sonic out of the picture and for good.
Wow.
So I think...
The train... Oh, okay.
You won't even let me pick.
Bro!
It would have been a better...
Better plot twist if it was Eggman disguised as the conductor and then he like pretended to get caught.
They didn't even let me pick!
Oh my god!
You got the 50-50, Rod.
Oh my god.
That would have been a better plot twist!
First we learn the train and now it's out to get us?
Yes, because it's a bad fucking train!
Once again, you keep saying the most ridiculous nonsense.
You're seriously convinced the train has...
...to get us?
I don't know what the train's full intent is.
AI.
I knew it.
Down with AI.
I fucking knew AI was gonna take over soon.
But we clearly have been tampering in our murder mystery scheme.
Train.
Come out and show yourself!
It's my birthday!
Amy!
And I don't need you messing with it!
Amy's hitting the wall with her hammer.
I'm with you, Amy.
This train can have it.
Come on, there's gotta be another way to get the train's attention.
What was that?
Did I do it?
Oh no, the train anki.
The train is anki, guys.
What did you do?
Is that the conductor?
Wait, he's not even...
Okay, like, his mouth is...
His mouth isn't even, like, muffled.
Like, why are you...
Here, I can get him down.
Don't touch him!
Oh, he's...
The arms!
The arms don't want the conductor to leave!
He's the train wife!
I thought I was the train wife!
But it was the train!
That's the train wife!
Is the train talking?
Of course I...
Of course I can talk.
You fools were too distracted playing your little game to figure it out.
We were right, weren't we?
What are you plotting?
I'm taking all of you to Eggman's base.
Where you will rot!
Eggman?
After I deliver your annoying party right to his egg fortress.
Annoying!
She has a birthday pass!
The conductor and I will be free to laugh and play games.
Ride the open rails like we always planned.
No!
Oh, train wife!
What are you...
Enough!
The train's...
The train's picking up speed.
Everyone...
Everyone grab something.
Which one of these buttons turns the trains off?
Sonic!
Me and my train husband.
Stay put until we arrive.
I'm the yandere train wife.
Goodbye!
Oh, wa...
I can keep my footing!
Ah!
Am I gonna meet Eggman?
There's more?!
What are th...
This was supposed to be a two-hour game!
A bunch of evidence has fallen out of my pocket.
My head...
Tails...
Amy...
Amy... is anyone here?
Hello?
I thought this game would end in two hours!
That's why I picked it!
No need to yell, but...
Sonic?
I'm so sorry, are you okay?
Hanging in there, it seems the train arms threw us back in the dining car.
That was the tutorial.
Now the real game starts.
But where's everyone else?
Quick question.
I like how in the end we actually...
I was like, it's funny that the Sonic game doesn't have a lot of Sonic.
And then the game in the end was like, no, no, no!
Obligatory Sonic here!
But for now, are you alright?
Sonic the Hedgehog?
Asking about me?
I'm special!
I feel terrible.
I'm doing amazing.
You know what?
He should know I'm...
He should not know that I have weakness inside me.
Amazing, huh?
He might have to share a bit of that enthusiasm with me!
Am I over?
It's okay.
Look, see?
He's giving me a thumbs up!
See?
He thinks I'm cool now!
Let's get our bearings and take a look around.
Good idea!
Leap away!
Alright.
Wait, what the fuck?
The arms are still like, working?
Okay.
How do we get out?
That yellow glow is chilling.
I miss when just showing us the weather.
Well, that's better than the yellow glow.
Oh, I see Eggman!
Hello?
Anyone here?
Why is no one responding to me?
I missed the yellow glow already.
You got some nerve showing up here, Egghead!
You spiky blue pest!
Seems you finally...
Jim Carrey!
Oh my god, Jim Carrey!
Seems you finally taking passage on one of my passenger trains!
You own this train?
I mean, obviously he created this train.
Who the heck are you?
Don't talk to me!
You're not famous enough!
Talk to me when you have 10,000 subscribers!
They certainly didn't talk about you in my interview.
My involvement is a well-known civilian.
Alrighty then.
The infrastructure in your towns just wasn't cutting it.
What if I were to build Eggman Land?
These problems would need to be sorted out.
So I courageously got involved.
I converted some cargo trains into...
Wait, so he was helping?
What?
He was helping the economy.
For the sake of the public, it's just more useful for future schemes.
Oh my god, he's so nice!
He helped the city's economy by fixing the public transportation.
Let me guess, another Death Egg?
Doctor Predictable?
The people feared giant spears.
It's science!
Let's cut to a chase.
We're our friends.
Judging by my security cameras, you're pathetic.
Your pathetic friends are all locked in the cars they were stationed in.
Wait, how does he know?
Wait, what?
Oh yeah, he was controlling.
Controlling our fucking murder mystery.
Seems you managed to make the train quite upset.
Did you not know this was happening?
Heavens, no.
I'm only now getting caught up.
I'm too far busy to notice what a passenger train is up to.
You see, the capability is normally very basic.
Just kill Sonic the Hedgehog.
Haha, that's so cute.
It's just like the first Sonic game.
But for a luxury train, I want to be sure things ran without my supervision.
And report to me if any of you happened to be aboard.
This train's capable intellectual thought is extraordinary.
A feat only accomplished by my genius.
Because he has a doctorate.
So this confirms it.
The train really is sentient.
Synthetic.
Except this to say.
Your capture is innovative and blah blah blah.
You are not a train.
It desires nothing more than to deliver you all to me.
See, I got to thinking.
I might need it to manufacture motivation beyond programming.
So I made him fall in love with the conductor.
Hahaha.
It's good for productivity.
So I instituted a bounty upon my army.
First to capture your pathetic creature gets a generous award.
The train wants to deliver us to Eggman for a reward?
Most of my robots ask for something simple.
Like my autograph.
Or whatever.
But a highly intelligent train may ask for something more interesting.
The train wants to be hot!
Hahaha.
I can see it.
As much as I like to reward programs.
Are you done blabbering, Doc?
The train wants to be put in a hot android dog wife thing.
So the train can kiss the conductor.
And be not just train wife.
But regular wife.
You know?
You can never just win silently, can you?
When you're dragged to my base.
You'll regret the day you ever crossed me, hedgehog.
I already do.
Get lost!
Ciao.
He always knows how to get under my...
Why is he blushing?
What the fuck is that?
Just got off the call with my boyfriend, Eggman.
Hahaha.
This is tough.
The train has the motivation and being made by Eggman is no doubt powerful.
Not to mention we're all separated.
What am I supposed to think?
The train purposely had Sonic knocked out so it could deliver us to Eggman.
This whole time we were all in danger and I went along with it.
Ah.
Sonic was really hurt.
That conductor's been captured.
Should I have been more assertive early?
Bro, what would you do?
What would you have done?
You literally...
You are nothing in this train.
Like...
I didn't try hard.
No, I tried as hard as I can.
I'm just a fucking regular Sonic OC.
I...
They're the same answer!
Am I at fault here?
Uhhhh...
Okay, yeah.
I knew Sonic...
Okay, that was sort of my fault.
I knew Sonic was hurt all along.
Hey.
I can tell the situation is getting to you.
Oh yeah, sorry.
I...
I get it.
The road's getting tough.
It's easy to question decisions I got to hear.
But when negative thoughts hit you...
Just...
Don't be sad.
Hahaha.
Sonic, this is terrible advice.
But when negative thoughts hit you...
Let it pass.
Just stop being sad.
Fucking hells.
Hahaha.
Haha.
Sonic.
I need you here helping me think this through before I do something rash.
I can't believe that Sonic cured my depression.
See, I'm one of those leap before you think kind of guys.
Haha.
You try not being depressed.
Thanks, Sonic.
Now I will never be depressed.
Haha.
Okay, you're right.
Hahaha.
Let's keep moving and make things right.
I'm cured.
Thank you, Sonic.
For telling me to breathe.
Okay.
Alright.
We gotta get to the conductor's car before the train arrives at Eggman's base.
You should switch your therapist out for Sonic.
Had to use Super Chat.
Thank you.
Guys, I don't need to go to therapy anymore.
Sonic told me to stop being sad.
I'm fucking cured.
The doors have been heavily fortified.
How do we get through?
Just use your fucking spin dash.
Sonic, I'm sorry.
I will be right there.
Believe in yourself.
Haha.
No matter the odds.
Believe.
Believe it.
I know you have what it takes to figure it out.
The entire day, Tails and I have been asking ourselves, what would Sonic do?
So, what would you do?
What would I do?
Well, I'd speed through head on and rescue my friends.
By any means necessary.
I knew it.
Spin dash!
Did I do it?
Oh, I have to fucking...
I knew it!
One big wind up sonic spin dash was fast enough to get that door open.
Now that's the road's clear.
Nothing can stop us.
Better hold on to your pants.
I don't think we'll be getting another break after this.
Ready to go?
Yes.
Let's do it.
Did I do the fucking spin dash every fucking room?
To the conductor car.
The end of this mystery!
Does it go through every fucking room?
Let's see.
Because then I'd be...
Oh, what the fuck!
Okay, real game.
Alright, our friends are locked in the cars up ahead.
In my last adventure, maxing out my ring count gave me an extra boost of speed.
If I can grab enough rings, I should be fast enough to burst through the next door too.
Oh my god, it's full screen time.
Let's do this.
The sprites are so cool.
I love the sprites for this.
Let's see.
Okay, guys.
Okay, this is not looking so good.
You know what?
Maybe we aren't gonna be saving our...
No!
Okay, there's no way.
They're gonna be like super generous with these.
Oh, I just...
Shit!
Just wait till I see Eggman, y'all.
I'm gonna clobber him.
We gotta deal with the train first.
Come on, let's go.
Hm.
Is Knuckles gonna join me?
Wait, Knuckles is not even gonna join me.
Guys, exact rings.
How does she do it?
I knew I just needed exact rings.
Oh no.
It's like each level is like...
Each of the mechanics they...
No!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
This is rough.
This is so rough.
No!
Oh!
I just got it too!
Oh my god!
Okay, I'm fucking doing it.
Alright, I hope it doesn't make me restart.
Ah, you all came for us.
Of course, but let's move.
The train wants to take us prisoner and earn a reward.
My reward is to get off this stupid train.
Let's go!
Alright.
I'll get to 60.
Is this the one where it's like the missile?
Or is it still the spinny thing?
Oh, nothing is popping up.
I don't like that.
Why is nothing popping up?
No!
Okay.
Okay, we got it.
We just got it.
Nice.
I'm getting better.
Spin dash!
Sonic.
It's about time.
I thought you were supposed to be fast, Sonic.
Okay, why don't you save yourself, fucking bitch.
Okay, we got a movie too.
Ready?
Always.
Let's boogie!
Alright.
Oh, it's just a...
Okay, these one I'm not as scared.
Cause like, it's just like the missile and I can dodge those.
Like, I just need to...
I just need to...
She didn't even say thank you!
She was just like, where were you?
Fucking rude, man.
I literally saved her at so...
Oh, exactly.
But it doesn't matter.
Cause I am an overachiever.
Okay, this one was really easy.
Alright.
They locked Amy.
And Tails in the conductor car.
Say no more.
Let's go!
Alright, last one.
This is the one where...
Stuff will start disappearing, right?
God, no.
I missed the fucking...
Oh, it's 55!
They gave me less of a challenge!
Nice.
Okay.
55.
Okay, I was gonna be so scared that...
I like...
That was like last.
That should be it.
Spin dash!
Sonic!
Sonic, you're here!
Heh.
Is this a way to treat...
This is no way to treat that birthday gal.
You're right.
I'm gonna stop this train.
I'm ready to stop this train.
Time to finish this.
Nice.
Is that it?
Did I...
Did I do it?
Excellent work trapping these pests.
Now hurry to me.
I must properly dispose them to begin my plans for Eggman Land.
Wait, he just wants to build an amusement park?
Like, what's so bad about that?
And probably another death...
Okay, maybe that's pretty bad.
Death Egg!
Don't teleport us to the...
Yeah, maybe not teleport...
Yeah, don't teleport us to the future!
Teleport you all to the future when I've already ruled the planet?
Sure, I'll do that.
Whatever.
Shut it, Eggman!
Don't disappoint me, train.
Hurry it...
Hurry it up.
I will not fail.
My wish will be granted.
I will be hot robo dog wife.
Your wish?
Oh yeah, you mean the bounty.
I don't care what you call it.
Just bring me those overgrown mammoths.
But he's a mammal too.
Wait, what?
That Eggman.
Yes, because the conductor is a fucking dog.
Guys, don't be freaks.
The conductor is a dog.
I must get my wish.
I will not fail.
This is it, everyone.
Get ready.
We're taking this thing down.
There's more?
Oh, wait, what?
Oh, my god.
Oh, shit!
He has arms now!
I mean, he always had arms.
We're good.
It's okay.
We're almost at 65.
It's basically like that one where the fucking meteors were dropping.
Except now there's their arms.
None of you could possibly understand.
We promised to be together our whole lives.
Oh, friends?
Sure.
Shut up!
Just shut up!
We're really, really good... friends.
Alright, let's grab some more rings.
We're very close to...
Oh shit!
Okay.
Alright, we're done here.
Yeah!
Eggman!
Can you hear me?
My wish!
Make the conductor never... Oh my god, that is so sad, bro.
Make the conductor... Bro, just download yourself to a phone.
Everybody has phones.
Never leave me!
Let us be... friends!
Forever!
The kind of... The kind of... friends.
Who would never leave each other!
Why would he betray me?
Bro, that's sad, bro.
Alright, here we go.
And they were just roommates, Chad.
They were just roommates, guys.
Alright.
Here we go.
Oh no.
We're not getting a lot of rings.
I hope I didn't miss a lot.
Bye.
Oh, fuck!
I left that chat!
Okay.
This is it.
Oh, I just made it!
Oh, thank god!
Conductor!
You promised me!
You promised!
Let him speak unhandom!
Hey guys, it was great that you guys helped along too, guys.
Train, stop this.
I told you we'd be each other forever.
I was a...
I was a much younger man.
I'm getting old.
I'm getting tired.
I can't keep up with you anymore.
Excuses!
How dare you abandon me!
I'll be lonely!
So lonely!
Why must you insist learning this upon me?
Hehehehehehe.
Oh!
No, stop!
What are you doing here?
To me?
Whoa!
Please don't make me do this!
Oh!
We have to rescue the conductor if we ever want to stop this train.
Robot!
This is too far!
That's fucked up!
What the fuck?
Bro, what?
Is the train gonna fucking kill me?
Like...
Oh, he's just blowing like the floors below me.
Okay, I thought it was like...
Oh!
Okay, never mind.
Never mind.
Things got more intense.
Oh, yep.
Things are... Whoa!
Things are...
Whoa!
Oh!
There's a lot of things going on on my screen!
It's okay.
I made it.
Okay.
Alright.
Nice.
I hit the train.
Oh my gosh.
Is this a three-hit thing?
No.
Okay, thank god.
Oh, there he is!
There's the bird!
Bro, it's powered by one fucking bird.
That... Those are some strong fucking legs.
A Flicky!
This is just like the lore card when my ex-best friend left detective work to join Dr. Eggman.
This really is... a bad... bad egg.
The stakes are rising every second, huh?
A Doki bird.
We gotta save him, y'all!
Howdy!
On it!
Let's show our full power.
Oh, guys!
Guys, are you guys gonna help out?
Guys!
Are you guys gonna help out?
No?
Alright, let's do this.
By myself.
Let's go.
You know, I always... I assumed that he was gonna help me out.
Like, you know, like, my team would wanna help me with, you know...
killing the train.
Alright, let's see.
Oh no.
Okay, thank god.
Woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah!
Woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah!
Oh, thank god!
Okay, I still have just enough rings.
Sonic's got this.
Is this three hit?
Like the usual Sonic games?
Yes.
To be delivered to Eggman already?
What about my happiness?
Your happiness comes at the expense of others.
Last I checked, that's called being selfish.
Whoa!
Me?
Selfish?
How dare you!
Oh no, one more hit.
That's me, three hits just like Mario.
I can't believe I said that for a Sega game.
Okay, let's go.
Oh my god, there's so many things going on my screen.
Nice, okay.
A hundred?
Okay, okay, I didn't realize.
Okay, guys.
Guys, I don't know.
I didn't realize.
No!
Not enough rings?
Okay.
No!
Don't make me...
Okay, it's still a hundred.
Oh, thank god.
I was gonna be like, that's gonna be it.
I fucking...
Oh my god, this one's so hard.
This one's...
Why is like...
The last one always has like a huge difficulty spike.
I did that before too.
Okay.
No!
I couldn't see.
There's two...
No!
Guys, I don't...
Guys, I don't know!
The last one always has like the most insane difficulty spike!
Oh my god.
Okay, here we go.
I'm gonna do this.
Guys, hey, hey, hey.
You remember I have a team that's just watching me?
Oh man, what a great team.
What happened to SPO?
The one that knows...
That's the ninja detective that knows 17 of us.
He knows 17 languages.
Why isn't he helping me?
Okay.
Whoa.
Oh, I did it!
Oh, please don't hit.
Oh!
I did it!
Okay, there we go.
Pro gamer tip.
Avoid the spike.
Thanks, Gwen.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
No!
Oh!
Oh my god, he's tired now.
Oh, now you're tired.
You've been in that train for a very long time.
Don't worry, I got you.
Wait, what does he eat?
It's over!
How does he even eat and drink water?
Time to pay for ruining my birthday!
It's as simple as that.
Crusader, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, that's so cute.
The little heart.
Where's my arms?
Floating knife.
Stab, stab.
Okay.
Nice.
That's cute.
I know.
Oh my god, my hero.
The train is slowing down.
Great hit, Amy!
It was pretty great, wasn't it?
That's what you get when you mess with my special day.
Hi.
I just couldn't bear to see you go.
I'm sorry for the trouble.
Oh no, he's gonna cry!
That's looking great.
I think our work here is...
Oh my god, he's so heartless.
Now let's get off this thing.
Train wife.
No, train wife.
Give train wife a kiss.
I'm sorry.
Thank you.
Goodbye, my friend.
I may be...
Jesus, fuck, man.
I may be leaving the rails.
But I'll assure you, I'll never forgive or forget our time together.
Jesus, fuck.
Train wife.
What does real wife have...
What does land wife have that train wife doesn't?
Huh?
Train wife has like...
200 plus hours.
200 plus arms.
Is that it?
Oh, there you go.
We did it!
Oh, we did it!
You know what they say about 200 plus arms.
Well, I say, I've never been on a train like that before.
This universe has a unique way of doing things.
Watch your step.
It's over.
The mystery of Sonic the Hedgehog's murder is officially over.
Maybe next birthday.
We just asked Vanilla to make dinner.
Yeehaw.
Oh, you don't love parties where by the end someone tries to kill you?
I think I'm going to miss this group.
Unhinge way of thinking.
Oh, God, no wonder.
Yeah, train wife.
Honey, you're late.
I've been waiting here for hours.
I'm sorry, train wife.
He made the right choice.
Yeah, sorry, bro.
You'll honestly never believe what happened, bro.
What?
The...
He's so fucked up.
It's just like a story to him.
By the way, Train Wife was like, Now, my train husband!
And then he's like, oh honey, let me tell you about this crazy story I had with the fucking train.
It was everything for Train Wife.
But the train was just an afterthought.
So I won't even try.
I'm just glad you're here.
Quick!
We leave for Spagonia in the morning.
And you need to pack!
I'll pack faster than the wind!
I need this vacation!
Something terrible!
What?
I need this vacation.
Something terrible?
Wait, I need this vacation.
Something...
Wait, does this make sense?
This is...
Oh, okay, I can't.
What does that fucking mean?
It's... oh, it's an idiom?
Oh, it's old man talk.
I was just like, what the fuck is this sentence?
Sorry.
For those who actually knew what that means, that means you're old.
And I need...
And I need you home.
Happy first day of retirement, dear.
Seems the conductor is more than ready to begin his retirement.
Hey honey, let me tell you what happened with my crazy train ex.
Thank you for the superchat, Gwen.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm happy for them both!
Oh?
Who's this?
An old friend, I think.
Well, they're a cutie.
That's for sure.
Cheep, cheep, cheep.
Seen that Flicky found a friend.
I hate that name.
Like, I'm sorry, but Flicky is such a terrible fucking name.
It just sounds so bad.
Great job saving that little guy, Espio.
This was the least I could do, Sonic.
Everyone, I sincerely apologize for the trouble I caused.
Don't be.
You're just following what you thought was their game.
It's hard to know what I would have done in the same situation.
I wouldn't have hit someone with a blow dart.
Seriously?
A dart?
It would have been hard to get close to you otherwise, Mr. Speed of Sound.
Regardless, I am sorry.
We're cool.
And now that we're all safe, it was fun!
This group has a wild idea of fun.
Boy, I am starving.
I forgot we never ate.
With all that clatter, I completely forgot I was hungry.
Me too.
I was distracted playing detective.
Did they even eat?
They never even eaten at all.
If only you had seen me, Sonic.
I was finding clues, presenting evidence, poking holes and alibis.
Sonic, where did he go?
Oh, is it chili dog time?
Everyone, guess what?
Chili dogs!
What?
Cake?
Oh, it's live too.
Where the fuck is my chili dogs?
This station has a bakery!
And look what I bought!
A birthday... wait, what?
That was so fast.
How did they somehow have Amy's face on a cake at a nearby bakery?
A birthday cake!
To the confident, unshakable and radiant Amy Rose!
To an adventure of a birthday, darling.
A memorable party... I don't have pants?
I'm sorry.
A memorable party every year.
Howdy to a fun birthday.
A ride... a ride from start to finish.
Just like my dark soul.
May our friendship grow stronger each celebration.
I admire your tenacity.
May you never lose your vivacity.
What?
I don't know.
Happy birthday to Amy and her sparkling person-acity.
I'm blue, ba-da-dee, ba-da-boo.
Happy birthday!
I'm not smart enough to know if person-acity is a word.
Me too.
Because I'm you.
We love you, Amy!
Happy birthday!
Ah!
You guys!
We almost got murdered by a lonely train!
But!
I like how they do this all in front of the train corpse.
Like, that's like the most fucked up thing for me.
Like, there's a fucking corpse of a train there.
And they're just like, yay!
I will trade these adventures for anything!
Never in a minute!
Like, do they not feel anything?
Like, that train was like fucking depressed.
But like Sonic says, just stop being sad.
Never in a million years!
You guys won't ever leave me, right?
Wouldn't dream of it.
Now let's have some cake!
Yes!
Please!
Dig in, everyone!
Yeah!
I hope it's chocolate.
Hmm.
It's her!
Oh, it says, let's go, Dad.
Oh, that's so cute!
That train's never making it here, is it?
Hmm.
Horbot, prepare the bath!
Let's go, Dad!
The happy rubber duck or the an- The happy robot rubber duck or the angry one?
Angry!
So, I'm gonna go get my stuff.
Sour Choice, your evilness.
Shut it!
That's so cute.
Let's go, Dad.
And that's my story of when I met Sonic and his friends.
Entangled in their lives for a fleeting moment.
And it backed the things as they were.
Cities realized Eggman was running the train station.
And fought back to seize control.
Everything's squeaky clean now.
As for me, I quit my job.
Wait, no.
Okay, if I stuck with the gig, that means train wife is mine.
Do I keep my minimum wage train job for train wife?
Or... or like... or quit, guys?
Stick with it?
I could have train wife.
I could have my own train wife.
Okay.
And then...
Won millions in the lottery.
Okay, won millions.
And after all that, I...
managed to fly...
Why would I... I already did that on stream.
Managed to fly to space.
Yeah.
That's just been my life.
Guys, I got my own train wife.
Now I'm a floating to me.
Oh my God.
Holy fuck.
That was five hours.
Oh my God.
It's not even April Fools for East Coast anymore.
And then everybody stood up and clapped.
We did it!
Yeah!
That was fun, though.
I'm really happy that I actually finally...
tried out this game from start to finish.
I'm always wondering what this game...
I mean, I'm naturally a big fan.
It obviously was about the murder of Sonic the Hedgehog.
But I always wondered what was this April Fool's game.
That was really fun!
I really had a lot of fun though.
I haven't voice acted like this in a while.
Me and my four...
Like me and my three voices that I can do.
You know?
But I'll say thank you to the official Sonic channel for...
For drawing...
I don't even know if that's the official Sonic channel.
If it was, I'd like to say thank you to the Sonic the Hedge...
Was that even the...
Was that the official Sonic the Hedgehog channel?
If it was...
It is?
Oh my god!
I'll say thank you to the official Sonic the Hedgehog channel for watching me play this game.
But that was really fun.
I had...
I honestly had...
Oh my gosh!
That is a...
You typed so long that the fucking alert got cut off.
Oh my god!
But yeah, huge shout out to Sonic for watching me play Sonic the Hedgehog.
The murder of Sonic the Hedgehog.
I had a lot of fun!
The artwork was like super fucking cute too.
And...
It was just fun to like do an April Fool's stream.
It might not be like super elaborate and I was just a tomato.
But...
I hope you guys had a fun time watching this with me.
Is there an after credits scene?
There is?
Okay, we'll stay guys.
Apparently...
I don't know.
I might have got one guide.
I could have...
I could easily get one guide.
Kaz!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The biggest prank was how conductor mama converted me to the Sonic fan of I understand now.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm just saying.
I understand why the conductor chose...
chose the land wife over train wife.
I understand now.
That's so fucked up.
The train...
The train wife was like putting their entire soul into like how much they love conductor as a...
as a friend.
As a really good roommates, you know?
And then the conductor was like, oh my god, real wife.
Let me tell you about this.
Oh my god, real wife.
It was such a funny day.
I'm just like, what?
That was such a funny day.
Real wife.
Oh my god.
Ha ha ha.
Poor train.
Poor fucking train.
So someone was like, I'd make the same choice.
It was so fun.
Shout out to America.
The Sega team in America.
For making this.
I also thought it was made by the JP team.
So I'm glad the Sonic, the official Sonic channel actually fact checked me and was like...
I was like, no, it was actually America.
And I was like, oh my god.
Fuck yeah, America.
Yeah.
I like assumed it was Japan because they always go super all out when it comes...
When it comes to like April Fool's shit.
Because they are like super dedicated to it.
I don't...
I honestly, I'm like...
I got one guide.
There was no fucking...
There was no extra credits scene.
I can't believe it.
I got fucking one guide as always.
God damn it.
Um...
Anyway.
I had a great time with everybody.
I am gonna call it a day tomorrow.
I...
Sadly for those who didn't read Twitter.
I will be canceling tomorrow's stream.
Um...
Because I will be like...
I want to be like working and stuff.
So tomorrow to...
Because um...
Um...
Uh...
There's been...
I need to like stabilize.
I've been going way too fast in my career.
So tomorrow I will be like working on stabilizing myself and making sure to like look through everything to make sure that like restructuring how things are done professionally behind the scenes.
So like we don't like miss out on things.
So that's why tomorrow there will not be a stream tomorrow.
Um...
I'll pin that on the...
Uh...
On the schedule waiting room.
So like if people were like where's the stream?
And then they look at the schedule they'll be like there's no stream.
Um...
But yes everybody.
I hope you guys had a great time.
And I hope you guys had a great April Fool's with everybody that's been doing April Fool's stuff.
Um...
I hope you guys had a fun time watching.
As always everybody stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me head to bed.
Cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys, hmmm bye.